oh [ __ ]
the church of what's happening now
is brought to you by
lyft let me tell you something lyft
knows how to treat their drivers and
that and they know what keeps them
moving
so they do everything they can to make
sure that drivers are happy on every
trip you understand me
join the ride-sharing company that
believes in treating its people better
and correctly go to lyft.com
joey today
and i can get you a 500 new driver bonus
that's lift.com
joey again lyft.com
joey number two
do you know depending on where you get
your mortgage you could save twenty
thousand dollars or more but eighty
percent of people only get one mortgage
offer and if you just go to one bank
chances are you'll get ripped off period
lending treat doesn't want that to
happen listen when i applied for the
house in my loan i mean i didn't buy a
house
but they just offered us a number and we
didn't even check or anything so i know
this happens i don't want this to happen
to you
are you sure you got the best deal we'll
find out how much you can save today
with lendingtree.com church again
lendingtree.com
church lending tree llc nmls number 1136
terms and conditions apply
get ready to rock [ __ ]
oh [ __ ]
the church of what's happening now
is brought to you by
lyft let me tell you something lyft
knows how to treat their drivers and
that and they know what keeps them
moving
so they do everything they can to make
sure that drivers are happy on every
trip you understand me
join the ride sharing company that
believes in treating its people better
and correctly go to lyft.com
joey today
and i can get you a 500 new driver bonus
that's lift.com
joey again lyft.com
joey number two
do you know depending on where you get
your mortgage you could save twenty
thousand dollars or more but eighty
percent of people only get one mortgage
offer and if you just go to one bank
chances are you'll get ripped off period
lending treat doesn't want that to
happen listen when i applied for the
house in my lawn i mean i didn't buy a
house
but they just offered us a number and we
didn't even check or anything so i know
this happens i don't want this to happen
to you
are you sure you got the best deal we'll
find out how much you can save today
with lendingtree.com church again
lendingtree.com
church lending tree llc nmls number 1136
terms and conditions apply
get ready to rock [ __ ]
[Music]
church of what's happening now
monday september 11th
[Music]
[Music]
there you go [ __ ] it's a
beautiful day to be alive
9 11 a terrible date in history but [ __ ]
it we moved on that's what makes you a
[ __ ] american
my heart goes out to the people in
florida
irma now jose's coming 22 [ __ ]
spanish [ __ ] hurricane but anyway
we're here with queer lee syed the
original christ killer
and my beauty queen of the church miss
[ __ ]
okay quickly i love you we were talking
about something interesting with you in
the beginning
years ago i'll never forget years ago a
young steve rena's easy came up to me
like
he was all sour pussed up and i know
what the [ __ ] your problem
he goes man
the last [ __ ] three pilot seasons
i've been to 12 producer sessions
four screen tests
and i haven't booked [ __ ] i go every
time you do one of those you get closer
to your goal yeah
you know and look a year later he ended
up on that fx show it was a hit the
whole [ __ ] deal
and you were talking about that you had
a bunch of stuff going on a year ago and
then now
yeah you're headlining places people are
showing up
yeah i was just saying like it's it's
interesting because i mean i'm from a
small town and i get messages from
people like all the time from back home
and they're like congratulations you're
doing so great you know like somebody
the other day sent me a clip they were
watching me on the avian awards like
it's just weird because people send me
that and i'll literally be like in the
99-cent store like trying to buy food
you know what i mean because
stuff is sweat like it's so up and down
this business and that's what i was
saying to you like
sometimes you feel on cloud nine like i
just did like four weeks on the road i
headline people came which is a lot
because of you like a lot of church came
yeah yeah yeah
and it was great and the podcast is
doing well like stuff is doing well but
then at the same time you feel like
nothing is happening because my show got
canceled last year i was on show time i
keep going to like producers on stuff
and not getting it i have a great agent
but i'm not getting tons of auditions so
it's just it's interesting because i
think
it's easy to make it look online like
you're crushing and then even other
comics will come up and be like oh my
god congrats it's going so well but the
truth is it's like it's like the
teeniest baby first step it's like
nothing really not nothing but
it's just i've been depressed and i'm
always like very bubbly online and i'm
always be two nice roommates
and one crazy one yeah yeah yeah
just the same dumb [ __ ] that anybody
network right up with time to time
and i read the thing and then we're
gonna go a little edgier like if fox is
trying to go edgier this is 2007.
okay this guy was like a druggie and a
drunk oh wow so in my mind it was ripe
you're like perfect for me
right before i quit doing blow yeah and
i'm like [ __ ] it i'm going to stay up
all night and get coked up
and go in there looking like the guy for
real hilarious i snorted coke till about
four
i drank a couple gin and tonic so i got
this wreath like alcohol
a method i probably slept like four
[ __ ] hours
and i walked in there like at 10 15
and they asked me to leave
shut up because they knew right away you
were [ __ ] up oh i was gacked up my
eyes oh god that jaw was going that's
crazy
yeah that's that's not the best way to
do it you're not right for this part at
all but
uh it was a stupid thing i did but the
moral story is that
i just did a move with adam sandler it
came in second to a [ __ ] right kid's
movie sorry i really won we only lost a
weekend by a million dollars to
some animated movie so we were really
the number one [ __ ] movie i figured
the phone wouldn't stop ringing
i get it
you want to hear the craziest la story
when i the first year and i should
always think about this the first year
that i lived here i used to do paid
audience work i don't know if people
even know like a lot of shows you know
you go like chelsea lately when it first
came out you would sit in the audience
they'd give you like 100 bucks if you
were decent looking to sit down in the
fronts you're on camera and i would do
that for extra cash so one day i'm doing
craig ferguson it was 75 bucks you're
there two hours i'm waiting in line to
go in there's a guy behind me and he
looks so familiar and i was like hey man
i feel like we've met do i know you and
he was like oh i get that a lot and i
was like no i'm pretty sure i know you
i'm like how i'm like what do you do and
he's like well
i used to be on a tv show do you ever
watch soap operas
and i was like i don't but my mom
watches them and he was like well i was
on general hospital for like three
seasons he was a serious regular on
general hospital and then he's like but
then i got killed off and things have
been tough i haven't been getting work
and he was doing paid audience work and
i remember at the time thinking
[ __ ] like because in my mind i was like
once you get a tv show
you're good to go it's never over no
never
no it's crazy it's crazy weird you said
something that i've been telling lee for
years
and i didn't want to believe it i never
wanted to believe it because i thought
the world was a paradise
it's not i thought that people worked 40
hours a week and on the weekends
everybody got bacardi rum and you went
on somebody's balcony and you were cool
and [ __ ] but then i'll tell you that
bacardi rum costs 25 a bottle there's 18
people there right and you got to pay
for 22 [ __ ] bottles well it's
different
all this [ __ ] no so we're raised on this
confusion and then you move out here and
you realize that
first of all
if you go to a beach
for the day let's say tomorrow morning
you wake up you turn on ktla and it says
going to be 98 degrees
and you
call your hot girlfriend and you go
let's go to malibu let's go down to
hermosa beach for the day and you go
down then you get in your car at 12
o'clock you land the beach you put your
suntan lotion on and you get a call from
a manager agent that says
you need to be at [ __ ] paramount at 1
30. that happens
all the time
so this is part of your [ __ ] life
that has driven me crazy for years and
this is what i tell people
you can't do nothing you're so right you
really can't you can't do nothing you
can't even when i take like one day that
day that you're gonna go to disneyland
with your kid you know how many times
i've been ready to leave with mercy and
terry and i'll get a voice over audition
or theatrical audition day of
and you go to yourself this is what i
get for leaving because i knew the rules
you know that's how i got my sag card i
never already got my side card i was at
home and my agent called it was when
spike fierstein show was on the air
there was a show on fox it was like you
remember it yeah my agent called and
said hey they're shooting this sketch
you're perfect for it if you can be
there in 20 minutes you got the job and
it was it was my first ever like union
job and if i hadn't been home ready and
not just home like not just home and
available
makeup on i mean you basically have to
be ready to run out the door and hop on
camera sober but sober you can't go
[ __ ] drink it two in the afternoons
at a bar no because you never go and
know when you so i learned this by 2000
i was like oh
this is a [ __ ] nightmare like i used
to go down to hermosa beach for pizza by
the pier there by the
comedy magic club yeah up the corner
they used to be the best pizza you ever
had there were guys from jersey we would
all meet at the comedy store every
afternoon a bunch of comics and drive
down there for pizza you know many times
i was on down and i sat down and i get a
call to go down to a [ __ ] santa
monica audition for a commercial yeah
so you you cut it out of your life
you're right it's a different commitment
i've even been like i've been trying to
take sundays and chill like i've been
trying to take sundays off but then like
even today my friend got a last minute
sunday audition like they were having
call backs today for i mean it was it's
for commercial was for a national
commercial and he got last minute like
straight to the callback i never hear of
that happening on a sunday but it can
happen anytime a couple weeks ago meet
with ben stiller on the sunday oh yeah
he said that two in the afternoon
because that's what they're doing now
this is not listen
30 years ago in this country you could
survive
by working five days a week and taking
off and letting your mind cure and
whatever [ __ ] job you have in mind
that's not gonna happen no more dog
first of all you know you know me so
well these people take the weekends off
and they gallivant on the week and i see
it i see it i've seen it with comedians
i've been doing that for years
i remember one time a comic came to me
who was doing phenomenally here
phenomenally and he was doing it by
himself he wrote a treatment and sold it
to fox by himself wow i mean this kid
was on a roll he was at the store one
night and a big name saw him and started
taking him on the road and i'll never
forget what this kid did and i i'll
never forget this he got married
like a [ __ ]
on a friday
out of town
but it was like a two-week thing the way
you said that and when he told me
you know you want to get married you get
married the day after christmas when
they ain't gonna call you for a job
you're right you're right you better get
married the day before thanksgiving i
haven't taken a vacation in five years
no there's no [ __ ] thing no vacation
vacation is when you go on the road for
comedy and youtube you're going the day
early you're going a day early you do
radio thursday and that thursday
afternoon before the one show you're
right you go for your little
duped you go to that restaurant
everybody sends you because the rest of
the night you got two shows a night and
you ain't got time to be [ __ ] around
the daytime it's crazy you have to be
focused for those two [ __ ] shows you
have to grind
twenty two dollars to come see you
you're so right and you wanna go hang
out with your buddies and suntan well
you're gonna be prepared for two shows
you can't even take break though when
you're on the road during the day
because you know what happens i'll go
out of town like i'll go for a weekend
and i'll come back and i'll have no
spots that week unless i was making
calls and [ __ ] while i was on the road
it's just it's never ending
and i think that's what happened is i
just i hit this point recently where i'm
like
[ __ ] i'm like grinding and grinding and
grinding but then suddenly you feel like
you hit a plateau and then it's like
that's the moment when it's so hard
you're like where do i push extra what
do i do extra but i'm so exhausted are
you guys at home i'm gonna be as honest
as i can with you i am a [ __ ] [ __ ]
by
by rule we're hard workers we work we
break our back i'm one of those people
i'm going to tell you something right
now guys honestly honestly honestly
from
october of 1993 i want you to look at
your [ __ ] calendars
from october of 93
to
may of 2004
oh no to
july of 2004
i was out
seven nights a week doing comedy
i'm gonna tell you people that from the
heart
i started coming in 91 i thought it was
like a [ __ ] one a week type thing
then i did like twice a week when i went
to new york here i am in the [ __ ] uh
heart of comedy and i'm doing three
spots a week where you could do 20. dude
you're right can i tell you something
crazy 11 years i did not watch a tv show
i did not know what sounded live was i
did not know what anything that's how i
am too because i don't know if you're a
real comic
you don't know what anything is then
people give me [ __ ] because i don't know
what's because then when you go out on
auditions or you have meetings like i'll
go to networks and i'll have to research
what's on the network on the way i did
it for years i didn't know joe rogan was
on when people when i first met joe
rogan and they were like he's on news
radio
i thought he did radio i thought he did
news right yeah i thought that he was on
am radio yeah and then my girlfriend at
the time goes no he's on a show on nbc
and that's how you know a real comic
that's when you know when somebody's
working i was just dating a guy who's
like an actor comedian he was so
offended because i didn't know any of
his work and i'm like i don't watch t i
literally never
i turn on netflix at night i fall asleep
that's the only time i even turn it on
and then i pass out watching it so i
don't retain anything so those years
where your
the years like from year two it's like
marco at jiu jitsu
i've been going over there for two and a
half or two years
maybe two years no a year and a half and
marco's been there for a year at first
when he joined over there he had he was
coming in three times a week he quit his
job now he goes to jiu-jitsu every day
every day yeah every day some days
and he's getting amazing right he's
getting amazing yeah he already passed
me he's got a stripe on his belt why
because that's what he decided he wanted
to do yeah
and he did it once comedy is one of
those things that you dibble dabble at
first but once you jump into it you jump
into it those nights when you stay at
home with your girlfriend on thursdays
and you have hands and watch cheers
that's gone but it's not even just
enough to go to do spots because it's
good i do spots probably five six nights
a week if i can get them and then but
the thing is it's not even enough to do
spots at night now with social media and
[ __ ] you have to be doing something
always you have to be doing like the
hollywood pool party or doing like the
periscope every morning or i mean it's
just you can't ever take three four
hours and just chill because someone
else is working harder and i'll see it
like i see it on social media and i'm
like [ __ ] these people are doing all
these things yeah but here's the thing
also i don't want to live on social
media
i want to touch them and leave them
alone and let them hit me up and go dawg
where the [ __ ] you been i don't want to
be that guy good idea because if you're
on there all day yeah yeah now you're
just going to be over saturated and
boring
everybody else yeah social media is
great but it's becau it's grown into
something else now
you know like i said two weeks ago
somebody posted that we used to use
social media as an escape from life now
we're using life as an escape from
social media how funny is this
you're taking pictures of your food
you're taking pictures of your friends
you're taking pictures of [ __ ] birds
right to show your world yeah that's no
need for that i don't want the people to
know what to eat i don't want people to
know who the [ __ ] i'm meeting with i
don't want people to know i'm standing
in front of a rock it don't matter who
gives a [ __ ] about well it's all fake
anyway you make your life look however
you want it to look but it's not that's
not real i am so yeah
you need to focus in areas you know i
get hit up by people constantly there
was this guy last week that i had to be
rude to
i had to be rude and i didn't want to
and i'm going to tell you why i was rude
since day one this is just my opinion as
a comedian i don't want anybody to take
it the wrong way especially you
or any other comic this is what works
for me yeah the the characters and the
and the the things in this part of the
show are for me
as bad as bad as i was on cocaine
and as bad as i was after a show i could
use a [ __ ] bump of coke yeah you know
what i'm saying kate quigley's here i
need an eight ball cause with a gram i
could put that monkey to work you know
what i'm saying yeah
you know what i'm saying so we got to
come up with a quick 150. thank you i
had no idea that was a compliment yeah
well i i i'm flattered once can't
quickly shut if i bumped into kate 12
let's space if i bumped into kate
anytime before 2005.
i let her have two or three cocktails
then i take him by the side of things
but you might have just keyed in on why
i'm single okay i want to blow a [ __ ]
coat brock and your [ __ ] and eat it
what do you think and kate would look at
me and go give me 15 minutes
if the guy shows up i'll leave with him
if not i'll let you blow a coke rock in
my ass oh what the [ __ ] and you sit
there you got an eight ball and you come
back and you you know when you have that
little condo in la jolla
yeah and
we'll talk for a while we'll talk about
comedy i'll take another beating from me
and then i'll [ __ ] put a coach
no
i'm just saying i'm just saying during
all that stuff yeah
i didn't sell a cd
i refused to sell a t-shirt yeah
i have a bad problem with prices of
tickets
you know i cancelled kansas city improv
this year because they try to [ __ ]
around um i respect the people who come
to my shows i don't like to sell
merchandise
i don't like to sell merch yeah i feel
[ __ ] weird i had to yell at this guy
because because t-shirts are not my
priority t-shirts are something that's
like a luxury for me i hate i wish i
could buy them and just give them the
[ __ ] away
because that's how much they irritate me
[ __ ] selling that [ __ ] but you have
to do it today if not you're not part of
the crew i didn't sell merch for the
money i sold it because if not people
think you're something weird with you
like do you have any coffee cups it's
weird though
when i was on the road with red band we
did it the first two weeks and then in
phoenix i was like i just feel it makes
you feel it's weird to do the show and
then stand there and show stuff so i
just stopped doing that [ __ ] i don't
either but i want you to shake my hand
let's take a picture and underlay i
don't want to hear you
i don't want to take your beating i
don't want to do none of that [ __ ] i
don't want to see what size you are i
don't want to sign your [ __ ] shirt
take the square reader and run
comedy yeah i want you to [ __ ]
comment yeah
you're paying money to come see my
comedy again prices people getting
arguments from me constantly club owners
agents i get calls all the time because
you want to sell tickets for cheaper 22
and 25 that's what i'm [ __ ] worth
okay that's what i'm worth anything
after that i'm ripping
you know why because the [ __ ] ticket
people have a [ __ ] ticket thing on
there for seven dollars i don't make a
dime on that yeah that goes for those
[ __ ] thieves so
you know you get killed i don't want
people to go jesus christ joey you're
right it cost me 150 to come see you the
[ __ ] do you think you are you're right
who the [ __ ] do you a comedy show should
be the alternative to a film i agree
like if i take you on a date and we go
to a movie and it sold out and i turn
around and there's a comedy club let's
go over there 15 to get in a drink is
four dollars no they charge you 84
dollars i agree with that and then the
[ __ ] i got to feel bad for the people
because i feel like they got eye gouged
but then don't you feel like that's a
kind of underselling what you guys do
because the way the movies make money is
they have thousands of screens you guys
only make money for where you are at one
point
so like it
even though like if you would say oh
well then your ticket should only be 15
bucks like that's
you guys like you guys don't have to
make a living i see what you're saying
but i also like okay a movie's what 15
bucks 12 bucks i don't know now like
maybe a comedy ticket 22 25. i think it
should be double i don't think it should
be like 50. i think that's fair 25.
the tickets have to be more because you
have to rent out the theater and they
know what you're up to so hey i gouge
you that's why when you go to a theater
those [ __ ] when you get your bill
from a theater you're like what
are you [ __ ] crazy and they're like
that's that's legit dog this is a union
theater you go a minute over your time
well the problem too though is like my
favorite audience is like a
working-class audience they're the most
fun so if the tickets are too much yeah
exactly can't get them no i don't appeal
to people we [ __ ] caviar
i appeal to people we [ __ ] stay
cutters and they fart they scratch their
[ __ ] i think that's why their wife
smell it i love all that i don't want a
bad mouth anywhere but i think that's
why like there's one club in particular
i i play often that charges a lot it's
like 50 bucks for a ticket and the
crowds always suck it's always
pretentious wealthy older not that old
crowds are bad but it's just all white
people and it's just like
it sucks because if the tickets were 25
30 bucks then yeah you get like younger
people like hard workers like people
that are excited to laugh not people
that are like normally seeing broadway
shows that are like oh let's see how
let's see how this will be isn't it like
they never even go to comedy like it's
it's not as fun you're right i just
don't like to
it's so weird when you want to be a
painter or
something to do with art and then one
day money gets involved
you know money [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] up
sometimes and you're like well what am i
going to do
i did i have done this you know then i
think about
all the years i made eight thousand
eight dollars
were you happier sleep on the couch i
was happier though oh my god i used to
be so happy i was so like i made when i
was married i had a job where i made so
much money i used to do these gigs where
i would be like basically a spokes model
for different brands like high-end
brands like bmw mercedes i would make
like
800 bucks a week plus or i'm sorry 800
bucks a day plus per diem like i would
make so much yeah it was [ __ ] crazy
but i was miserable
i hated it i hated everything about it i
didn't give a [ __ ] about the cars i
didn't want to wear the outfit i didn't
want to talk to the people and then i
quit that and i got a studio in la in
the [ __ ] worst building you've ever
seen i literally had a naked crackhead
sleeping outside my apartment door in
the hallway in the interior hallway for
like a year and i knew him by name like
i would come out and he'd be like laying
there naked with like a boner first
thing in the morning i'd be like hey ted
and just walk down the hall
i slept on the floor i had no furniture
at the time i was married but my ex was
on the road doing like gigs doing other
[ __ ] and i was the happiest i'd ever
been i was doing stand-up and i was
auditioning and i just felt so alive but
i was making no money but i just hated
like that's the thing like i meet people
that go well don't you want more don't
you want to like get out of it like now
i live in a shitty one-bedroom apartment
people like don't you want to get out of
here and i'm like i don't really care
i'm like i'm happy now like even though
i say like yeah i get depressed when my
career is kind of slumping or whatever
when you mean depressed
i get depressed
like me you get depressed for 48 minutes
no and then you go what the [ __ ] is my
problem lately i've been depressed for
days but you know what part of it is you
know what it is i'll tell you
it's relationship [ __ ] because the thing
is you can't have i mean you do it
you're married and you manage to do it
but for me i find
starting a relationship maintaining a
relationship and focusing on your
building your career is impossible it's
impossible you have 92 guys you're
hunting no i really don't you're a 92 i
don't hump them all i do date i do date
around but i don't [ __ ] them all here's
the thing i once told a very funny woman
a very funny one give up
came up to me one day and she goes i
don't know what to do
anymore i'm gonna bring guys this and i
said listen
you didn't move to l.a to fall in love
no
okay and i understand the sadness and
the loneliest part of it people think
that when you're on the road
it's [ __ ] jumping up and down some
nights you're in a hotel for two nights
by yourself
and law and order you can't watch
anymore and you don't want to go
downstairs and smoke and i'm a girl so
i'm not taking audience members back to
my room like guys you know you might go
out and like bring back an audience
member i'm not doing that you know so
it's a little different but
it's just i don't want to fall in love i
don't want to get married again but i
want something more than just i show up
and [ __ ] you and that's it's almost
impossible to have
anything healthy and pursue my career so
lately i've been feeling like i have to
choose which is like i think that's
what's bumming me out but
i have had some really hot hookups
lately so it's not all bad but
no
no but i'm not what i want though that's
it see look
what you know
there's a thousand and one complaints
that women lay on you i sit here and uh
i cleaned out my desk a couple months
ago and one of one of the folders i
found all my
first couple years you know when you got
a spot at the store you steal the the
piece of paper from the wall
i found all of those i found all my call
sheets from
spider-man 2 and the longest yard and
law and order anything i had done i
found the call sheets you know
and i ripped out all those lineups
and i looked at
the thing and i first off the first time
i looked at
who's there it was still 16 [ __ ]
colonies in the lineup
there's always two girls so all these
women that are crying about today that
they don't put enough women at the store
it was the same [ __ ] i got the lineups
for
days in a row for years not as many of
us though okay so right away you've
never been one of those that whine
you've always gone after it
okay you've always gone after it
and that's where you gain my respect
because
some people like you said this is tough
this isn't like a year and then it ends
this is every day yeah i'm here 20
[ __ ] years and this morning's league
gets up and i've already [ __ ] tweeted
you know the whole [ __ ] thing written
i've already done a thousand things why
because i know
that something can happen at any time i
could get a call it's true and this
could all change i've lived here for a
long time i remember uh auditioning for
a movie april 5th
and having people call them every
[ __ ] day
and then one day they called me in july
and said
what are you doing tomorrow
you're so right and i go i'm not doing
anything why they like do you want to go
to a table read tomorrow about one
o'clock
and i said sure i'll be there and they
go all right we'll see that one and then
about two hours later they called back
and said hey
what are you doing after the table read
tomorrow and i go nothing they go
you want that flight you want to take a
flight down to albuquerque new mexico
with us and shoot for six weeks
so right there people people right
people have no idea when somebody calls
you on a monday that's true and says
tuesday at one o'clock you got to go
somewhere and at four you're taking a
[ __ ] plane you're right for new
mexico and you got to put all your
business in order also you got to lay it
on your your girlfriend or whoever to
watch your cat or your [ __ ] dog
you're right you've got to have somebody
deposit the checks because you're not
going to get paid on the set in
albuquerque
they're going to send the checks to the
house yeah you're right though man and
the thing is it's like you got to be
ready for that but also i can't tell you
how many times i didn't pick up my phone
and i caught back an hour and a half
later and the job is gone i mean you've
got to be so honest no i don't give a
[ __ ] when anybody tells you you know
when i when i first got when i first got
out of my marriage i uh i started dating
a guy a comic actually like a successful
comic and i remember at the time i was
really into this guy and you know he
said to me and i was pissed at the time
but now i'm so glad he goes you
shouldn't be dating me right now you
want this you should be out seven nights
a week doing it you shouldn't be dating
anybody
and he wouldn't see me anymore and i
remember the time being like [ __ ] that
guy i'm gonna [ __ ] blow up so i can
be like [ __ ] you man and i was angry but
then it motivated me and then i really
that's what made me start going out and
getting up like two three nights a week
listen all that lovey-dovey [ __ ] yeah i
don't really one day i totally i love
this kid with all my heart i know lee i
appreciate what you're doing with paul i
love it
but right now
right now
i've lived the life and i [ __ ] up my
life if i could do it all over again and
i was 29 28
there really would be no love attachment
until i made my first million dollars
because in this new world order and this
new society and what i mean love
attachment is
kate i love you you're my [ __ ] woman
i'm not gonna cheat on you nothing's
gonna happen but doug
i don't got time for [ __ ] games but
that is that is i don't know
that is a relationship no fun and games
is sundays i don't have time to meet up
with your [ __ ] stupid college friends
and watch the new england patriots and
have margaritas i gotta work
because that's a different you don't
lose the time it's so easy it's easier
for guys i need that there's there's
agents i know that i talk to on sundays
and they're going to work oh yeah i know
this is going to work at their house you
know attorneys i love attorneys because
a good attorney will tell you i don't
know what you're talking about i don't
watch football they never chill you go
to your office you're always doing
something even if you go do one hour's
work you're mentally there true you're
there listen we need
some people need a day off i've trained
my mind
that i take six hour blocks off
like a six hour block for me
you learn how to rejuvenate in six hours
that's impressive i think that what you
just said is what the problem is it's
not physically exhausting this work
that's immense but it it it takes a
mental strength
to just get through and like oh it's not
as hard
but it's it's just to always be on call
to always have it to always be on
it it does it it just drained the
battery a little bit more expensive
you're just always thinking like my
brain is always [ __ ] you have to be
when i was a kid my best friend was
gearhead and that's what they called him
gearhead because he was always la la
that's how i am i can
today is worth 10 [ __ ] million
dollars because while you were thinking
of
joseph and why he's not dating you and
if he's dated his girlfriend
was thinking about what's important you
said something very interestingly you
said it's very mental
whatever
at the age in 1994 i got mad at the
world i got divorced
and some people took her side some
people took my side you know [ __ ] was
going on i was broke
i was frustrated as a comic you get
frustrated as a customer and the
frustration is you want it's so [ __ ]
bad
you don't understand how bad i want this
so you figure out how you're gonna get
this and you know it's a plan
but i remember thinking to myself this
you know i tell lee i love them i told
kate i love when i talk to joe at the
end we say we love you the kids i grew
up with
i don't give a [ __ ] what you people say
you know in the sense of your family i
have a tight-knit group of people
you have to mentally
be strong and say to yourself you know
what if this person loved me he wouldn't
act this way or she wouldn't choose what
that's true i'm getting
rid of them
you're right
i'm getting rid of them
this is so stressful
that you can't the worst part of this
this and anything that has your mind
involved on a daily
is when you get caught up in somebody
else's life that's it well not just yeah
now i'm living with kate and kate
is depressed
the
sitcom got [ __ ]
my sick time is rocking and rolling my
sitcom is rocking and rolling on abc
yeah and yours just got cancelled
so now now i'm depressed and then you're
killing it and then there's this weird
elephant in the room yeah totally i see
that yeah and this is why i tell people
that you know what man there's something
in your you have to eliminate problems
you're right
and pick you up what is that expression
you have to pick your battles pick your
battles
you really do you can't worry that's why
when i hear people talking about
politics or the jets
or whatever look at that car that's got
three dents in it i go why are you
worried about this or trump or hillary
or [ __ ] pence or any of this [ __ ]
you got problems right yeah that's true
nothing really started to work for me in
my life
so especially with comedy you know what
i used to do every afternoon
i used to [ __ ] get up
smoke dope write a little bit go get
chinese
go see if i got check in the mail over
on gardner and then from there i'd hook
up with a bunch of comics and we talk
about our futures and i realized the
guys i was hooking up with i hadn't had
in the future what was i doing four
hours in the afternoon hanging out with
these guys getting depressed and i
eliminated them from my life
and next thing you know we're here
you know i heard the best quote somebody
said to me one time they said if someone
cuts into your self-esteem cut them out
of your life like if anything about them
is making you feel shitty cut them out
and it's
it's true i'm pretty good about it for
the most part but occasionally i fall
into one oh and it's not that it's just
there's people who come into your life
and they consume energy that's in their
friendship that's it and one day you're
like whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa i'm
sitting over here worried about this
person
and i got two shows that are sold out
exactly why the [ __ ] am i uh yeah you're
right there's just so many aspects of
the mind
you know it's like
it's like when people first come out
here you ever see a movie star blow up
right in front of your eyes
yes tiffany haddish
i'm talking about like i saw
that [ __ ] dude the dude that did uh
that they used to be i met our men's
roommates vince vaughn vince vaughn oh
vince yeah i saw vince vaughn blow up
yeah i saw vince vaughn blow up so hard
that he got over
saturated yeah
and they blew him up even so hard that
for a while he was just doing bomb
movies yeah
and that happens because it's the it's
the law
of diminishing
returns
you know yeah you cannot
take on 18. you and i both know that's
true
that's true no
if you came to me right now and said
joey you're on a tv show you're going to
do stand-up and i'm going to maintain
the podcast i'd sit down honestly yeah
and go okay so
the podcast is on sunday nights every
sunday because you can't do it during
the week that's a tv show there's no way
i could fit in there that just happened
to me you're right no way i'm gonna work
all day and come home watch my [ __ ] and
come in here and talk to some [ __ ]
guests and then be prepared for tomorrow
so sundays i'm doing that then i look at
my comedy schedule and i go you know
what i don't want to do this but i have
to do this this gets scrapped this gets
scrapped
you have a connecting flight this gets
scrapped this gets grabbed this gets
scrap put friday and saturday rooms
instead
there the whole time so i could stay
home till thursday yeah yeah you don't
want to spread yourself too thin it's so
easy i've seen 20 000 comics over the
last 20 years
start running with the ball and next
thing you know that same ball kills them
you know what i think it is because i
think it's when you're starting out you
want to say yes to everything because
you just want anything you're like i
want exposure i'll do your podcast
i'm talking about when you first start
out you say yes to anything
and then yeah
every year there's a shabbat festival
yeah the thing about shabbat yeah
right every september the shabbat
telethon
and they do it in beverly hills
and i'll never forget one day i'm an
acting class and as i'm walking out the
acting teacher conduct because come here
for a second
some guys called here looking for you
i go really and i read it and it's some
kids i call them up and they have like
an israeli accent
i was doing videos for shabbat and we
saw you and we want to use you
it does not pay but you know all this
[ __ ] it's going to be seen by
300 million jews
he goes
spielberg the whole thing we cannot pay
you i go let's [ __ ] do it
they [ __ ] called me on labor day me
and my wife had plans like we had just
started this year
oh back then
this has to be because we were talking
about the other day by telethon came out
hilarious i can remember that she goes
please i'll never forget that
we had just started we had been dating
like maybe two years
i was always on the road i'm finally
home one weekend and this labor day we
get invited to a party
and
something we have like a dinner like we
used to our big thing in those days was
sizzling
still my big thing if we went to sizzler
in those days
that was to celebrate like movie roles
we go to school it's amazing like if i
got a tv show you were the emmy when i
got the jazz momentary movie yeah with
the sizzler we spent 35 hours we're like
oh [ __ ] you're like steak knight oh my
god
and those are the stories that you do
yes you're right i was a little happier
back then you were happier
less you were uh
i think the happiest i ever was if i
wasn't dating the stripper i would have
had a much better time i mean i had a
lot of no guy has ever said that by the
way ever oh only i hadn't had this damn
stripper oh my god i wouldn't have that
stripper she was the poison of that time
i spoke to her today i checked up on it
because the hurricane was saying you
guys became friends we're friends man
that's hilarious listen let me tell you
something you had the taste in women
that i have in men now i think you had
it and then you like no i
dated this chick because i was married
i dated a chick that i was married to a
chick that one night by mistake i popped
it in a muffler
by mistake
oh yeah that's what every guy's doing
it's three in the morning three in the
morning i went for a piece of ass and i
put in the wrong one by mistake and the
next day she was furious
she woke up and she's like i bled from
my ass wait a minute wait a minute wait
a minute wait a minute something so i
was like i was married to that wait can
we discuss that for just one second hold
on so you accidentally put it all the
way in there like she didn't say
anything like halfway in like hey wrong
you're in my ass
she didn't want her and then she woke up
in the morning in pain and didn't
realize like she didn't say anything the
night before
i don't even remember
i'll never forget that the next morning
she said something to me and she wasn't
happy for a few days for a few days i
was
you know i went from being like a
lunatic
to being settled down for six years
i bumped into a few pieces of ass along
the way but nothing too crazy
they used to be this girl
she used to make [ __ ] cheesecakes she
was from hawaii she grew up in hawaii
and she used to make cheesecakes at this
[ __ ] cheese place it was just it was
called like a cheese restaurant but they
made sandwiches
but she worked behind the register she
made cheesecakes okay and she was from
hawaii and she was tremendous
i remember when i was about 19 that she
probably was about 20.
she had a boyfriend named kip
and i was friends with kip and his
goomba and we used to go up there and
she would give me a slice of cheesecake
oh i bet
she was tremendous she was beautiful she
was blonde real big
[ __ ] tits real yeah
like [ __ ] playmate type tits that
were real
banging body i liked her very much you
know i respected her she had a boy
i went to jersey for nine ten months i
don't know how much i respect when i
came back she was still there and now
she was dating a spanish dude like from
spain that was a chef at paul of france
she was in love with him and [ __ ] nice
and [ __ ] uh
you know we used to double date me the
girl i was married to at the time i
wasn't married to the girl i was
married yeah and the spanish dude i used
to be i used to be a house sitter
and i used to instead of
bringing them to my side of the house i
would invite them to the big side and we
had a jacuzzi and we had a from the
jacuzzi you walked inside and there was
a steam thing
like a steam room and then there was a
sauna yeah and then there was a shower
so you know for a few weekends on friday
nights they would come up and we'd get a
few eight balls
and we'd all go in the jacuzzi and she'd
have a little [ __ ] bikini on it from
time to time and she would ask me
creepy things and i always i had like i
was friends with her she'd ask you
creepy things right like what like i was
the only child you know like the like
why is that creepy are those the only
towers
like she would say those are the only
towns because i would need like a big
italic to make me get out of the jacuzzi
or something oh she just wanted to watch
you walk away no i didn't like i don't
know i don't know what the deal was
i want to see photos of you back then i
just sent you one oh that oh that's
right yeah but you couldn't see your
body so i was yoked so
so [ __ ] i don't need to see it
so
this this went on for weeks
and one friday night i went and copped
from this chick named neely burment
she had some [ __ ] great a cocaine i
mean it was [ __ ] tremendous [ __ ]
she gave it to your wax paper i mean she
was scared for
everybody was giving it to you aluminum
foil then or bindles
she was giving it to you in wax paper
but she wouldn't sell you nothing less
than a quarter ounce
like
yeah and it was 700 for a quarter ounce
the coke was that [ __ ] good it was
right off the cliff they ended up
blowing that dude up and his jeep the
guy she was getting the coke from yeah
they blew that dude up with a [ __ ]
jeep and [ __ ] blew him up blew him up
with a [ __ ] that coke was coming
direct from the [ __ ] colleague
yeah
and let me tell you something we went
back we were at my house and this [ __ ]
at the time the chicken turned me on to
this other they were lesbians
i was getting i was friends with a
lesbian chick and one night she gave me
a blast and i was like what the [ __ ] was
that and she goes this is the [ __ ] i'm
pimping she was friends with the hot
blonde with the big tits no no no no no
she was friends with the drug dealer so
she got me
thrown back to my place with this nitro
coke
and i gave the siege a couple lines and
we're having a good time we're talking
to me and the guy talking spanish
and she gets up and she walks out of the
tub kind of like creepy and looks at me
and i see that she walks in and she goes
into the steam
and i go you know what i got to play
this [ __ ] hand
no i was savage right there with my your
girls in the hot tub my girl's not a
total hug
i'm like get up and i walk right in
there and when i walk into the [ __ ]
steam bed she's sitting there with the
steam on
naked no no no she just had a towel on
no she had nothing on just a bikini
and then she goes what are you doing
here i need to cool off too i need to
warm up too it's kind of getting cold
she goes i know
and i when she said cold for some reason
i looked down and her nipples were hard
for some reason i just looked it
straight in the face and i go take that
top off like i just couldn't take it no
more did she do it [ __ ] yeah they all do
it i can't they all did i wouldn't do
that yes you would no i wouldn't you got
banging teddies like you got when you
got three or four lines in you okay
somebody says those tits are tremendous
take a little peek at those things she
dropped them put it back on
and that was it oh that was it oh that's
not the whole night
the story gets deeper and deeper like
the madonna stone he's pissed by the way
he's i'm just pretty mean that's
by the way this story is making my trust
issues with men so much worse because i
can't believe your girl's in the hot tub
and you're doing it i come back to the
hot tub we hang out till about four but
the chef had to go back to work at 6 30
in the morning
and he kept saying that i gotta i can't
snort at the fourth because i have to be
at the restaurant at 6 30. so she was
leaving i said i'll see you at 6 30.
just like that dog and she looked at me
she went like this they left
i [ __ ] went back and my wife was
stabbing ate a monkey she passed out i
gave her one of those cosby pills
i took a cosby pill i went inside
watched porn jerked off and about 6 15 i
marched down to a house i was too [ __ ]
up to drive i walked down there like a
soldier
[Laughter]
i knocked on the door she answered the
door with a robe
i showed the rest of the bindle and i
walked out of there at lunch time with
[ __ ]
red cheeks and a [ __ ] worn-out helmet
shut up
you [ __ ] your girl your wife no not
your wife yet then you jerked off then
you went and [ __ ] her no no then he
took a walk because i took a walk to get
the testosterone coming back
i walked a mile late
i don't understand that how are you
going to justify that to your wife i was
21 years old well he wasn't married yet
no
no
his car was there when he took a walk
quickly that was a savage dog jesus i
walked back in that lunch she was still
sleeping my wife went to bed at six
coked up oh so she was asleep at lunch
but she wasn't my wife she was my
girlfriend let's get this [ __ ] then
you're married i was 21 yeah married yet
yeah yeah yeah you were you were it's
fine
holy [ __ ] i just don't know why but i
walk down there listen it knows when
you're 21 you get 19 hard-ons not to
mention the blow and she was beautiful i
mean just looking at her i love that
that makes me answer the door with a
[ __ ] robot
yeah i just walked in we started making
that did she know you were coming did
you call her no i told her on the way
out i looked at him and he kept saying
you winked i have to be whole i have to
be at paul of france at 6 30 in the
morning
so i looked at like oh i see you at 6
30. and she looked at me feeling like
this and i was like oh [ __ ]
this was easier than what i thought
this is at first i got really paranoid i
thought the boyfriend was to call me and
say did you tell her
you were going to come over at 6 30. i
just said see you since 30.
and that was the end damn
but she made the best cheesecake you
ever had you [ __ ] went oh well then
all right that's what did it for you the
cheesecake
we went from [ __ ] suffering and
comedy
today
do you want me to do you want me to tell
you my my bad vegas no not yet i'll save
it i don't want you to be depressed no
more you're actually okay you've been
here for 11 years
and you have to it goes up and down
that it goes jesus
listen i got here from 98 to 2005 i was
off steam ahead
and then 2006
it kind of weirded out
and then 2007 i got my name is earl
i did four episodes they were gonna he
liked me greg garcia he goes you know
what i'm gonna we were only gonna do
like 10 episodes in the jail we're gonna
do all the second half of the year in
the jail so just show up every week i
was gonna get like [ __ ] ten episodes
on my name is earl yeah and especially
during pilot season you know what that's
like people watching my name is always
hot yeah so people are watching me on tv
during pilot season there's a [ __ ] tv
strike oh i know i know then the economy
went up so here was the deal
when the economy went belly up at that
time i was living off residual checks it
was 2007. the longest yard was still
sending me big checks yeah spider-man 2
was sending me [ __ ] i was making a
living off spider-man too
and then all these little tv shows i was
doing were sending me checks so they
kept the house alive yeah my 50 gigs
with george perez and felipe esparza
rudy moreno and gregor and jeff garcia
those gigs were paying
you know if you hustled back then come
on pay more yeah you made 650 a week as
a nobody comic yeah it's amazing every
night those mexicans paid money
everybody had a room monday night you
picked up 40 bucks and you went to the
ice laugh factory and picked up 25. yeah
then you went to the store for the 15.
you know and that that all adds up you
don't get you you get 40 that in a check
in 10 [ __ ] days but at least you're
working towards something and then
tuesday night we were going to casa
latina and that paid 50. yeah and then
from there there was a guy who had a
room in whittier and that paid 75 so you
picked up one in the [ __ ] quarter on
a tuesday wednesday you could make
it's like being it's like living in new
york now
if you get in at those clubs you make a
hundred thousand dollars a night yeah
you're good all those guys do are we all
those guys
that's not in new york that's like
enough to live in someone's closet yeah
but still still no you're right 150 200
you have to be out there every night
right and you and i both know that the
day you take a vacation the day you fall
in love and go
all these singers yep all these female
singers from [ __ ] gwen stefani to the
[ __ ] chick from the valley love [ __ ]
her and the other girl my hump my hum
my hump my hump what happened to her
fergie
love i'm telling you that's it done
i'm stupid can i tell you something can
i tell you something i have been like
hung up on this [ __ ] dude who's a
piece of [ __ ] meanwhile i have
super duper hot guys that will [ __ ] me
whenever i want and are great in bed and
i could totally just when i'm horny hit
them up and [ __ ] them and concentrate on
my career that's where girls [ __ ] up
because we catch feelings and then we we
pay attention to that dumb [ __ ] instead
of our career that's it you're so right
that's it you know what i wish there was
there needs to be some kind of like pill
that women can take that makes us like
act more like dudes like i want to be
more like a guy that's what i want i'm
already very guy-like but i want more
like i want guy feelings
i do want guy feelings you guys are so
lucky you're so lucky if i was a guy i
would leave here tonight i'd hit up some
super hot dude i'd go [ __ ] him mean girl
no well i'm saying if i was a guy
personality but like with my body and a
vagina i would go [ __ ] somebody and it'd
be amazing and then i would just go home
and not even think about it until next
time i was horny that's what i want
that's what i want but it's not that
easy i know but that's what i want guys
pay for their [ __ ] sins too let me
tell you what happens to guys bro you
don't watch the movie boomerang
no why would you i don't know lee oh
wait
the eddie murphy movie yeah you watch
boomerangly i don't believe so why would
you why would you you're too busy
no i think i watched it
i kind of congratulate you for watching
narcos finally
mama gave you the green light uh
boomerang is a very interesting story
if you're a guy like me we've all grown
up with guys that are very hot
and that uh
ladies men they're [ __ ] ladies man
yeah
okay is that boomerang it's that story
boomerang is a story about a guy who's
successful
good looking has all the toys
invites women over for dinner cooks with
them puts on black music and they you
know they think they're cool
and i
i never got it i never got
guys how women didn't see certain things
that i saw in guys that were flaws
so this guy that's all he does he [ __ ]
four different women a night a week
but then you meet your [ __ ] one and
that one
[ __ ] these guys up dog when you get a
guy at 30 and he's good looking but
there's something not right
like he doesn't let you come to his
house or yeah something's not right like
that day you do get to his house he's
cool he doesn't cheat on you but
something's not right but he's really
handsome and you know like trying to
figure him out like what's going on yeah
it's that somebody [ __ ] electrified
him
because those guys are so i know so
that's exactly that's exactly right i
had a friend i grew up with that got
different [ __ ] on demand
every night spanish dude yeah i'm the
man he fell in love with this white
chick that chick [ __ ] [ __ ] his
world up he walks around now he's like
on the walking dead i think that's it
i'm telling you i don't know for a fact
that's it
somebody's into an electrocution and
boomerang eddie murphy's character
gets [ __ ] up they threaten to fire him
like they threatened to fire him like
it's a stupid movie or whatever i'm
gonna watch it but my point is it's a
great [ __ ] chris rock was great
uh my point is that [ __ ]
it those guys play that they don't get
burnt for a long time
they live on top for a long time but
then they bump into a girl that flips it
on them
and these guys
they don't know what to do
yeah it was a quarterback that's it they
always been the quarterback and when
they get flipped on they get flipped on
like it's like [ __ ] bad you you're
married to brad pitt
but you cheat on him with a guy like me
like then he's like what the [ __ ]
that's it that's when that's what
happens to those guys you're right
that's what happens to those guys they
get electrocuted early and their [ __ ]
central nervous system
now you can't get them back listen let
me be honest with you and it breaks my
heart to say this i'm very fortunate
as a man i see
people who go sign up for groups
like um
singles groups oh and they go on
vacations
like you know you i just saw the ad
about a month ago like a singles cruise
or something like singles cruises or
maybe like a singles resort that sounds
awful well you go listen to me but you
have to think
and i'm not being an [ __ ] here but
you have to think when you go to those
things
if somebody's [ __ ] not married by the
age of 40.
never been married never been married
you have to look at those things and go
wow
what happened
like either no either they're [ __ ]
or they really just have bad luck with
women a couple weeks i was in a hotel
and i was having dinner at the bar and
it was saturday as i was walking in
hundred people walked out it was like i
was the kiss of death but when i sat
down i asked about to them what's going
on and he goes there was a wedding they
were all going to one egg oh thank god
so i'm eating by myself
and this guy comes over kate quigley
good looking dude
okay
35
athletic
um
well off you could see that you know he
was staying at the hotel yeah this was a
nice hotel i was there for a comedy club
uh the suit was tailored you know the
shoes were shined he had a [ __ ] together
it was color coordinated to the max
and he ordered a double
and the bartender said you're here on
business he goes no i'm here for the
wedding
and he goes you're by yourself
and i'm eating and i'm watching whatever
sporting event is on this poor bastard
knowledge
i know i'm here by myself but i'm
really hoping to meet somebody
and my [ __ ] heart bro that was me at
brad's wedding last weekend my heart
broke because this guy has it all you
know this guy from looking at it from
looking at it i'm looking at his shoes
i'm looking at his belt i'm looking at
his fingernails
i'm looking at his presentation just
because
just after he said that i wanted to see
what this guy was selling or if he was a
yokel i love that you analyzed his
fingernails as part of that this is part
of the tour
does he have cologne did he take a
shower right no yeah is this guy is this
guy [ __ ] single because he smells
like a goat's [ __ ] yeah no this guy
was done up he didn't have a tie out so
he wasn't lying to anybody which i also
liked
he had the button opened instead of
having a tie on
that means you're not looking for
[ __ ] people okay you know
and then he had another double and
he walked out and i went upstairs to my
room at the comedy shows but that night
i thought about that situation like how
does a guy like that
35 38 is still single he looks
successful he said he flew himself in
like he
flew in for the wedding
and the guy goes is there anybody here
you know and he goes
i think he grew up with the groom
but he lives somewhere else now so he
didn't know any of these people he was
coming here blindsided
but i could tell in the tone of his
voice
that this was a big thing for him like
he was hoping oh to meet someone at the
wedding
oh god and it broke my heart i was like
i was always very lucky you know i
always found some [ __ ] poor
woman that would fall for my [ __ ] i
never do
i never have a date to this [ __ ] you
know i went to brad williams wedding
last weekend i had no date and what's
crazy is you [ __ ] ten different dudes
how the [ __ ] i don't you call one of
them and go i don't [ __ ] a bunch of guys
you know the problem you know what i
realized the problem is the guys like
this dude i've been hanging out with i
thought we're dating we go out we go on
dates we're out in public we make out in
public i mean
like to me that's dating right but then
he was like he actually said to me he
goes well if i go to something like that
with you you know then like everyone's
gonna think we're a couple and i was
like who [ __ ] cares guys don't want
to be seen with me you know what it is
guys are embarrassing me i think that's
the problem because of because of my
social media because it's not facebook
official i don't know is it social media
or is it because you're [ __ ] crazy i
am crazy joey i am okay but wait i'm
crazy but i'm only crazy here's the
problem okay this is really the problem
i fall for the same type of guy all the
time and this is it it's guys that are
really sweet and perfect and put on like
the best show for like
three months just long enough to make me
think they're awesome and i'm like i
finally found a good one and then the
minute i cave and i'm like okay you know
what i really like you too then they
[ __ ]
like pull back and ghost out or barely
text me or stop taking me out or because
you let them go all the way you let them
take pictures of your [ __ ] and [ __ ] you
in the [ __ ] no i stopped
no i stopped letting guys [ __ ] me in the
butt because of you
you're welcome
yes once they [ __ ] ass they're not
gonna call you back the flowers i don't
do it anymore because you told me they
won't take me to dinner and then you
were right so now i don't let guys do
that unless we're together that's so
[ __ ] up that's like my promise ring my
butthole is my promise right
so you think of joey every time some guy
asks you sure you gotta block that
muffler once you give it away you're
done unless you move in and he's paying
rent for a few months and yes you got
the car payment going i even said it to
a guy i said joey diaz told me if i let
you you'll never take me to dinner again
i said that to him he laughed he cursed
you but he he didn't do it no he knows
they they giggle too because they know
listen once they [ __ ] in the ass and
they turn you around and they jizz in
your mouth why are they going to take
you maybe that's the problem maybe i'm
too flirty because when i like a guy do
i send them like hot photos and i'm very
sexual i can't help it i'm in my 30s i'm
so horny you're crazy i don't [ __ ] a lot
though but i'm horny women were horny so
i i can't help it like if i'm dating a
guy i wanted to [ __ ] me a lot i think
it's too much for guys i break them out
i just i'm i'm freaked out that you had
no problem with the doing anal and then
having you flipped around and come in
your mouth you just blew right past that
you're like yeah that happens yeah who
gives a [ __ ] that's another day at the
office
that's another day at the office it's a
bento it depends how clean i knew i was
i take good care i'm very clean
listen the hot ones always take care of
the engine you know what i'm saying
that's how you know if i think i'm going
to have sex i don't even eat that if
somebody tells you they have that good
piece of ass
when somebody's a good piece of ass they
really take care of that monkey
you're not going to go away with no
nothing you know what i'm saying i'm
obsessive because my one thing i know i
have to offer this probably shows how
low my self-esteem is is that i know i'm
really good in bed so and i keep my [ __ ]
clean and like everything is you know i
know a guy is going to want to come back
so that's the one thing i that's like my
trap
do you like a pep talk before you go out
or something
yeah i stand on a mirror and i give my
vagina a pep talk i think it's time for
tony bennett
oh [ __ ]
the church of what's happening now is
brought to you by
lyft let me tell you something lyft
knows how to treat their drivers and
that and they know what keeps them
moving
so they do everything they can to make
sure that drivers are happy on every
trip you understand me
join the ride-sharing company that
believes in treating its people better
and correctly go to lyft.com
joey today
and i can get you a 500 new driver bonus
that's lift.com
joey again lyft.com joey number two
do you know depending on where you get
your mortgage you could save twenty
thousand dollars or more but eighty
percent of people only get one mortgage
offer and if you just go to one bank
chances are you'll get ripped off period
lending treat doesn't want that to
happen listen when i applied for the
house in my loan i mean i didn't buy a
house
but they just offered us a number and we
didn't even check or anything so i know
this happens i don't want this to happen
to you
are you sure you got the best deal we'll
find out how much you can save today
with lendingtree.com church again
lendingtree.com church lending tree llc
nmls number 1136
terms and conditions apply
get ready to rock [ __ ]
[Music]
church what's happening now
monday september 11th
[Music]
down the beard of wisdom
brian o'shea
roz dude who gave us some tremendous
weed
[ __ ] family to the church
david maca a bad [ __ ] and indy
gooner i love you [ __ ] don't
forget this saturday me and [ __ ] kate
at the cherokee casino
and then in two weeks 9 27 or something
like that the pittsburgh [ __ ]
improv
i'm coming in heavy because i'm not
doing philly this year so i got to do
pittsburgh and the other side hold up
all right so what the [ __ ] happened to
you in vegas
oh my god all right i really really want
to name the name of who this was with
but i'll tell the story and people will
probably figure it out by the way this
has never happened to me before so it's
not like i do this all the time no okay
so
so so i'm in vegas i'm doing the lab
factory and i was there for a whole week
so
i have a friend in town who is more like
an acquaintance a guy i've hung out with
a few times who's performing in one of
the shows in town this guy is
the hottest i mean he's a very famous
very hot
guy actor model type like he would be
like halle berry if you were a chick
okay so we've always had a flirtation
but i never hooked up with him because i
had a crush on one of his friends so i
didn't want to ruin my chances with the
friend so whenever we would hang out i
would kind of blow him off so
after my show at the lab factory my
girlfriend really wanted to meet him so
i go okay i'll take you down to his show
but you have to promise no matter how
drunk i get
don't let me leave with him because i
can't [ __ ] him no matter what happens
and she's like okay i got you
so we go to the show girls are terrible
no not really i'm trying to be safe i
like his friend right
so
we go to the show
and um i have two drinks at the show
that's it but it was like 112 degrees in
vegas and i've been at the pool all day
i must have been dehydrated because i
had two drinks and i was
[ __ ] up like i was so buzzed and then
this guy comes out on stage as part of
the show and he takes a shower on stage
he takes off his clothes and his butt is
facing the audience and he like lathers
up with soap and the women are going
crazy and i'm watching and i'm like
i might i leaned over to her i go i
might i might have to [ __ ] him i might
change my mind you might have to let me
go she's like no i'm not letting you go
no matter what so then after the show we
go to meet up with them
have a third drink
now i'm like wasted
and i said to her if you don't let me go
home with him we're not friends anymore
she was like okay but i think you're
gonna regret this tomorrow you're really
drunk and i was like it's fine you know
i'm single [ __ ] it who cares like if you
had a chance to [ __ ] halle berry you
would [ __ ] halle berry right
okay
so i go with him he's not staying in a
hotel they put him up in a condo there
this is important because there's no
maid service at his place so we go back
to his place
we get inside
we [ __ ] on the balcony it's so hot we're
like overlooking the strip we can like
see there's people in a pool like a few
floors down
it's super hot i'm so buzzed that i'm
like getting off like three four times
right away like that fast then he [ __ ]
me again this guy's in his 40s so he
came once then he got another condom
then he [ __ ] me again then after the
second time he's like i'm gonna hop in
the shower and we're gonna go for round
three
so
i'm like great so he hops in the shower
all of a sudden
i start to realize how drunk i am you
know when you're like in a club and
you're drunk and then you go to the
bathroom and and you don't realize how
drunk you are until you're in the quiet
and like the room starts spinning
so the room starts spinning
so like
i haven't gotten so drunk that i threw
up since college all of a sudden i feel
like i'm in a puke
and i didn't know what to do because i
don't want to puke in this guy's
apartment like he's the hottest guy ever
so i start running for his kitchen like
i'm like maybe i can puke before he
comes back out and he won't know i start
running for his kitchen before i can get
there like right by the bathroom i start
puking all over the floor of his condo
everywhere and then i didn't know what
to do so i turn left and run in the
bathroom he's in the shower
and i just start throwing up all over
his bathroom floor like imagine you're
in the shower and the girl you just
[ __ ] just runs into your bathroom
naked puking you don't know what's
coming and he starts yelling at me he's
like what the [ __ ] are you doing what
you're puking everywhere i'm like i'm so
sorry and i'm saying it and i'm like
projectile vomiting and i ate salad
so i puked salad greens like lettuce all
over his bathroom floor his shoes his
clothes by the way i think they're like
5 000 shoes i puked in his shoes he's
like
[ __ ] puke in my toilet what the [ __ ]
i'm like i couldn't get there i'm trying
to talk and i'm throwing up at the same
time so bad and then i i puked in a sink
i filled up the sink it clogged the sink
then i start running for the toilet and
then he goes
this is why i don't [ __ ] white women
because he's a black guy
so then
[Music]
i'm in the toilet and i'm puking and i
start crying because i'm embarrassed and
then i was like i know you don't know me
that well but i swear i haven't done
this in like 10 years like i haven't
been this drunk in so long i only had
three drinks like i'm trying to explain
and he was like oh [ __ ] they ain't
coming to queen for a week he's like
[ __ ] he starts grabbing towels there's
joey this is embarrassing but there's
like lettuce from my salad how much
salad did you eat i ate a big kale salad
right a huge salad there's salad greens
the whole bathroom is white on the walls
on
just everywhere and he doesn't even know
yet that it's in the apartment too he
hasn't gone out yet
so he's like get in my shower so he
shoves me in the shower i'm naked
i puked
in his shower he turns on the water so
now there's cold water on me and i'm
like i'm so cold just i go make the
water warm and just give it give me a
blanket
so he goes i don't have any towels left
i used all the towels to clean up so he
gave me a hand towel
so i passed out
on his shower floor naked with just a
little hand towel with puke in my hair
puke everywhere on the floor this is can
you imagine like this guy was watching
me passed out gross and then it gets
worse did you put this on instagram [ __ ]
no i was so nervous when i woke up i was
like what if he photographed me because
here's the thing
then i guess in my sleep i was making
noise because i was in pain i think i
had alcohol poisoning for real so i was
moaning in my sleep and i was like dry
heaving and then i started hearing
banging it's like 3 30 in the morning
and it woke me up and i was like is
there a construction
he goes
security is at my door shut up don't
make any sound i was like just open the
door and tell him i'm i'm sick he's like
i have a naked white woman passed out on
my bathroom floor i'm not [ __ ]
opening this was like right after the r
kelly [ __ ] happened he was like i'm not
opening the door so he wouldn't open the
door security's there for like an hour
banging on the door
because they could hear me moaning i was
moaning i was like oh i was like dry
heaving joey for like two hours
i was so humiliated and i kept
apologizing i kept telling him
you don't know me but i haven't done
this since college i've only met this
guy like four or five times
so then
i finally fall asleep i sleep quietly
till 4 30 5 a.m i wake up
i stumble out this poor guy is cleaning
my puke still
i stumble out and by the way all my
friends are like he's such a dick i'm
like no he's not i would be pissed too
i'm not even mad at him but i stumble
out i'm like hey can i get like a
t-shirt i'll just sleep on the couch
he was like [ __ ] that you leave it he's
like you're not staying over and i was
like i don't want to put my clothes back
on i was wearing like a skirt and like
yeah i don't want to get redressed he
goes
where's your phone i'm like why he's
like i'm calling you an uber i'm like
why don't you call it on your phone he's
like i am paying for your uber he
wouldn't even pay for my uber so he took
my phone he called me an uber
and then i went to put my heels on he's
like don't put your heels on i don't
want the neighbors to hear you like he
didn't want anyone to see me he was like
so embarrassed to have me in his place
so i had to walk out
puke in my hair
walk down the hallway carrying my shoes
you wouldn't talk walk of shame
walk downstairs call a [ __ ] uber
and then go back to my to my room and
walk through the lobby of the tropicana
like this like and go up to my room and
then the next day i texted him we were
supposed to go shooting we're gonna go
shoot gun shooting the next day i text
him i go i'm so sorry about last night i
swear it's never happened to me before
but um i'll pay for a maid to come clean
up your place you know he just wrote
back i'm good have a nice life
and did you understand this is the
hottest guy i've ever [ __ ] one two
he could have been ongoing like great
booty calls like he could have been the
booty call he was so good we had
chemistry it was great i don't like him
really you know what i mean like he
could have been like my ongoing
situation i have no feelings for and i
ruined it i puked everywhere you need to
eat more than just kill next time let me
ask you something
i want a guy puking in your [ __ ]
house
no but it's not my usual routine
but if i ain't puking it's something
else i never had a guy puke in my house
but to be fair i've never puked in
another guy's house once i did puke in a
car but that was when i was 22. the last
time i puked i was 22. but the reason i
told this story is just because even
though it's so embarrassing it's so
funny because it couldn't have been
worse it couldn't have been a worse
person
well it could have been worse
how have you puked on him during sex
you know what's funny people say that
but i feel like then at least he would
have been like well
like if i would have you know that he
[ __ ] you like into sickness or
something no i don't know like at least
if it was in the height of the moment i
could have some excuse maybe i could say
like you know you i don't know i choked
on your his dick or he was i just came
so hard
i don't know
but i mean like i still feel bad and i
hope he hears this and i just want to
say i'm sorry i really feel bad
this is why i don't [ __ ] white women he
said this why i don't and then also but
here's the more interesting thing more
the friend who introduced me to him that
i have the little like crush on which
probably now we'll find out about this
um
he said like if the guy's name was jack
he said this is the jack curse
meaning like this has happened before
with other women that this guy has
introduced him to like apparently he has
like
uh like a number of women that this guy
introduced him to that ended up pulling
some crazy [ __ ] on him oh my god but so
i just i'm i'm sad do you think that i
can fix it though no
do you think there's any chance like
honestly no okay
no
no you're not puke kind of ends it
especially if it's not like
into the relationship
no because i had a friend that
i was friends with in boulder and we had
had like a little fling cocaine thing
one night in boulder
and then two or three years later i went
to
miami to do the coconut grove improv and
she called me she goes i live in fort
lauderdale now
do you want to get together i made it
come down and we got a package and went
back to the condo
and we did some disgusting things
and then there was one point where i was
just watching the news i was coming down
from coke
and she got sick
how but like did she just puke in the
toilet or did she puke everywhere she
puked kind of everywhere because she
tried to go for the balcony
she was going to puke off the balcony
yeah
you know
oh man i better have been
i would dry heave off that balcony in
miami tons of times you did i was a dry
heaven that's why i don't drink that's
what i did we'll see i'm a dry listen
when you wake up from a hangover
there's an acid in your stomach not to
mention you did blow
or you ate some [ __ ] pills so that
shit's in your stomach so the first
thing you do is you drink some [ __ ]
iced tea
right
why is i don't know something with
lemons and it's something to get that i
send you down something and then you go
outside and you stick your finger down
your [ __ ] throat i can't do that i
might puke every piece of alcohol out of
my [ __ ] system you could feel the
hangover i don't headache
really what's that [ __ ] get out of my
system i just work out i sweat white
foam
oh that white foam comes out then you're
done now you're ready for something
greasy
to synthesize the [ __ ] cells you can
put it you can put the finger down your
throat i love that you picked lemon as
the most non-acidic like that's the most
acidic i don't even know what i'm
talking about but this is what worked
for me well i can't make myself puke if
i could i would that was the only way i
could get rid of that hangover really
just by sticking my finger down my
throat and puking out that
that [ __ ] from the beer what the [ __ ] i
was drinking the night before but here's
the thing you know me i mean i have two
three drinks all the time i never have
more than three but i have two or three
all the time and i never throw up i'm
very i'm a very controlled wait what's
the first thing i tell you before when i
call you at 5 30 every night before a
podcast
eat something because we're gonna go
deep
yeah but three drinks doesn't matter you
don't know how it works
was kale you never know how it's gonna
hit you he gave you he gave you a dose
of good dick
you know what i'm saying
you rocked that little [ __ ] he threw
your equilibrium that's a bummer he was
made to go back and forth so he [ __ ]
up the equilibrium and the next thing
you know you got sick and he wasn't lazy
that's the thing like you know i don't
like to hook up with famous people
because they're usually lazy and bad
because they get so many women they
don't have to try he wasn't lazy it's
such a bummer i ruined it i'm going to
try you know what i'm going to do
i'm going to try to find a way to weasel
my way back into that situation as just
a part of the world that sounds like a
nightmare he's going to make you do
something you don't want to do it he's
going to make you blow one of his
friends or something
i'm not gonna do that
i don't think you would do that sure he
would we'll see
you all right you just sound like you're
gonna stalk him and just like end up
outside of his house no i wouldn't
actually that's i'm crazy but i'm the
only crazy i am is texting i'm not crazy
in any other way i don't show up at guys
houses i don't [ __ ] i don't do cr i
don't stalk social media but i do i'm a
crazy i'll send a guy like 50 texts and
i honestly do like i mean i joke about
it on stage but i really do like my mood
changes and then i change directions but
i don't wait for them to respond so i
look completely schizophrenic let me ask
you something
if you were a guy would you date you
like you don't need to yes
yes
but here's the thing why would you date
you you text all [ __ ] days no no i
don't text you [ __ ] crazy
joey i don't text all day
here's the thing if if a guy this is the
problem if a guy that i'm really into is
into me back i just relax and i have fun
with it the minute i trust him i'm so
chill the problem is the guys that are
really into me that will give me what i
want i never want them you know i spent
the day yesterday with
don't say it no no i won't say who i
spent the day yesterday with a really
wealthy successful hot guy who has an
amazing house and likes me so much that
he paid my personal trainer to come to
his house and train us together and then
he made me breakfast
and then we hung out all day two days in
a row and he's so respectful i barely
text him i never give him any [ __ ]
because i'm not as into him but the guys
that like don't want me
are the ones that i [ __ ] like lose my
[ __ ] over the games i know but i don't
want to play the game why can't they
just let me back that's the level of the
game they're taking you to i don't want
that game girls do the same thing it's
like you're putting quarters in the
machine like i don't want the game but
the problem is i play the game well till
i like them and then once i actually
realize i like them then i lose i
it's all about the sex though
if the sex is amazing i get caught up
then what do you expect but the sex is
only amazing when they're nuts even if
they're ugly you're reaping what you saw
you know what i'm saying i mean listen
in
1998-99 damon wayne's always coming to
the comedy store tonight okay i don't
know if you know this damon is really
funny yeah and he would come in at night
he used to have this bit about
how come crazy women always got the best
[ __ ] what is that
i don't think it's that we i say we i
call myself crazy you are crazy i don't
think it doesn't matter i think that's
what i like about it i think it's crazy
on crazy
it's not a crazy person alone because if
i [ __ ] a guy that's normal
the sex isn't that good it's when the
crazy meets up with another crazy it's
that volatility that's what makes it hot
i was fighting all day with a guy
and then we were fighting for like we
were fighting for like three hours and
then i said at the end of the fight
after i was like we should be all on
text right yeah yo because he won't talk
on the phone but after like three hours
i was like
after me being like we should be friends
you're a piece of [ __ ] i'm so tired of
you [ __ ] yourself after all that i was
like
did this fight make you wanna [ __ ]
really bad because i really want to come
over and [ __ ] tonight like literally
like the fighting makes me want to [ __ ]
that's the problem
the fighting makes me i love the
fighting the angry you have no idea are
there more women like you are you normal
oh no i had a girl this is the same i
think that this is normal
oh my god this is normal for many women
that's why women create drama oh it's a
pattern it's yeah no no but i'm trying
to change it i'm seeing the laugh
factory therapist
one on monday nights for 22.50 she's
free
it's free
so that feels like a like a twitter bio
line i'm seeing the laughs right there
i really am i'm trying to get healthy
she can't prescribe though so she's not
that great
kind of a bummer
but i'm trying to get better i want to
start liking sane people i just have to
figure out how
it's this sums for my childhood it's
going to be fine reprogram yourself i'm
trying
i'm going to give more attention to the
guy that paid the trainer and and you
know
that's it i look like you like you oh
i'm gonna i'm gonna lower my standards
to the millionaire with the big you love
being a loser magnet
it's not they're not losers though
they're not [ __ ] winners either
they're not doing nothing with you so
they're losers i mean
you have to sit there and be real as a
woman and go why am i attracting these
[ __ ] losers but the thing is they're
not losers like like like this dude he
does take me out he takes me out so it's
not like it's just a booty call you know
and he does like text me and stuff he
just
he won't give me the intimacy that i
want like he won't let me sleep over
he kicked me out at 3 a.m
that's why we were fighting she made me
leave at 3 a.m isn't that the opening to
bridesmaids
you kicked me out at 3am and i was like
why can't i just stay and then we'll
have sex in the morning then i'll leave
at like 8. and he was like i just don't
want you to think that we're a couple
i was like i don't think we're a couple
i'm just tired and he's like you live a
mile away drive home
you made me leave
and that's the problem i want the guys
that kick me out at 3 a.m
it's going to be fine did you steal like
a water or something on your way out
that's what i would do
if someone i get pissed off yeah i took
i took home a water or something a very
interesting life out here you really do
it's not real eventually you have to
choose between the crazy life and
these [ __ ] chicks that are leaving
here with a hundred million dollars
well this is the thing and then you can
[ __ ] every anybody you want you could
jump up and down you get chlamydia give
a chlamydia but that's the thing i can
already [ __ ] anybody i want i want more
than that but i don't want i don't want
a marriage i just want a little i want
to be able to spend the night
that's it
that's not that much i want to come over
after my set we get take out we [ __ ] i
spend the night we [ __ ] i leave we
flirty text that's it you're to get a
lot of applications after this problem
that one guy
i mean honestly if the sex is awesome
and i like somebody i don't feel the
need i'm not like a dude i don't feel
the need to like hook up with a bunch of
guys but if that's what the guy needs
you know and i happen to meet a like
male supermodel in vegas maybe an
occasional hookup maybe but i don't look
for it okay you were thinking you were
talking about being a woman and having a
man's perspective yeah okay i used to
have this friend
hot hot hot little piece of ass for
years i could never figure it out but it
wasn't my business to figure it out
she was a dear friend of my dear friends
but i was watching one night
watching her like just watching her and
then
she would travel with my buddy from time
to time
and i would try to figure out what her
deal was
and one day i went to a comedy club
and one of the comments was talking
about two weeks ago
there were these people here and they
were talking about him he told me the
comic's name and i go who else and he
goes that broad
and i go how was she man was she good
and comedy because yeah
he goes but it was crazy after last
night
before she left she picked like some
[ __ ] random guy
and she just
went off
like ass [ __ ] come in my face
tie me up choked me
the whole thing my jaw dropped she was
saying that there at the at the no she
wasn't saying nothing how did they know
about it because this guy was telling me
the story and the first time i heard i'm
like i don't think so i think this is
just a young comic talking [ __ ]
but throughout the
years i heard more and more
horrible stories about this broad
how
you know on the last night or the night
before the last night she would just get
a victim
from the bar take him home
give him a good piece of [ __ ] and then
leave town the next day and then she
would give him fake numbers and the
whole thing
but all these guys that were telling me
these stories yeah had the same thing in
common what she never came back to the
club
and she'd never speak to us again we saw
her years later at this place no way so
they're all just one girl
and years later i became friends with
the girl and thing whatever
but that was her stance
i couldn't do that i could go to a town
and she was very discreet
like i i went to a town one time and
they told me a story that after the show
she went to this club and had a
threesome
and that she made
something happen that she made the guy
i don't know i don't know the whole
story something weird i don't know the
whole story but
it was a weird little secret she had but
that was her thing
that's how she got off oh she heard
getting off was going through a town
picking a victim
taking him back to a hotel [ __ ] him
and then disconnecting with them
completely i can't do that i wish i was
talking to a person again
making sure no but this is not you can't
do this here because they know you're a
comic and they'll hunt you down that i
can't do it anymore you'd have to do it
if you traveled i wouldn't do it the
most discreet guy at the hotel
just go up to him and go meet me in the
room take him to the room tie him up put
ice cubes in his [ __ ]
the whole she was that type of savage
the problem is i don't know that's
thinking like a man i know she didn't
give a [ __ ] but like i wonder i guess
for her like the turn on was like
getting off on the power of like
seducing these guys but for me
i don't i'm not as into it unless i like
the mine like you won't believe me like
my number's really low even though i
have these like i do have these crazy
stories and i tell them all but my
numbers still like i counted the other
day because the guy accused me of he's
like how many guys do you [ __ ] and i so
i went home and i can still remember
them all it's only like it's in the 20s
it's low it's so low i swear to god this
is last month no i swear to god because
i was married for 10 years so i've only
been single five years it's only like
been five or six guys a year it's not
that many because when i find one i
really like [ __ ] i kinda i wanna keep
looking but i just i can't help it i hit
up the same guy when it's really good
and i don't
i have to kind of like him even
i've only had two one night stands only
two guys i've hooked up with once and
they weren't even really one-night
stands because both guys kept texting me
for a long time after it just happened
they didn't live in my
area so we didn't hang out again the
same [ __ ] thing as that broad
yeah but i'm just saying like
it's so rare for me to meet a guy
and be like i want to [ __ ] you right now
and then do it like i just i don't know
i don't know if it's because i'm
paranoid or if i have to feel i have to
trust him to let him in my room alone i
don't know but i don't do it very much
i really can't
is that weird
god bless you man a lot of kinky [ __ ]
happens a lot of crazy [ __ ] [ __ ] but
i love kinky dirty [ __ ] oh yeah but
that's after you know the guy that's it
that's it after you know the guy like if
you that's it
even the couples i've had threesomes
with i have to kick it with them a few
times
before i'll have like i've never met a
couple and just had a threesome like on
the spot like i can't do it i have to
like them both what do you what do you
do with them before the threesome well
like there was a couple in vegas that
came to see me perform investigate still
following you
um
the guy actually they broke up
and then the guy had the [ __ ] nerve
to show up at a show one night and like
flirt with me and i shut that [ __ ] down
i'm a girls girl i was like [ __ ] that he
asked me to go on a vacation with him i
was like are you out of your mind i
would never i'm not even like that good
of friends with the girl but i still
wouldn't do that they broke up because
of it yeah yeah well they broke up i
think if you have a lot of the thing is
they were having threesomes and the guy
was like stepping out on the side that's
the thing if you're having three if you
have a hot chick letting you have
threesomes and you're still trying to
cheat like you have a serious issue i
think this girl's hot
but anyway i we hung out a few times you
know they came to a show we had dinner
then another time we had dinner and
drinks i literally it was almost like i
went on like three or four dates with
them before it was like i was dating one
person but i was dating a couple i
couldn't do it the first time how would
you guys sit at dinner like
like would they sit on one side together
um i go chapel on sundays what's his
name the guy in the
narco on sunday he was married to three
different wives that was amazing
actually it was usually the girl was on
my side because it's always in that
scenario the girl's trying to make you
more comfortable you know because if the
guy does it it's creepy okay so it's
always the girl i've never had one so i
have no idea i don't know okay quickly
who are your personal heroes
heroes
this is gonna sound so cheesy but like
my mom is like my hugest hero i mean
that sounds so dumb but my mom is single
i think that's the way i'm with guys too
my mom was single and my mom would never
take help like we lived in a pretty
expensive neighborhood
and my parents split up when i was in
fourth grade my dad made a lot of money
but when they split up he just quit his
job like overnight he was like i don't
want to do this i'm not paying child
support so he quit
so my mom suddenly picked up three jobs
to keep us in the same school district
and like doing all the [ __ ] we were
doing
so she never slept it's crazy i never
felt like a poor kid even though we were
i took every class i took like karate
played soccer as a dancer i did all this
stuff my mom would sleep in the car and
then she worked nights and she worked
days
and she wouldn't take help i think
that's actually in some ways like i
remember one time we were at a grocery
store a guy in line behind us my mom's
car got declined and this guy tried to
pay for her groceries and my mom would
not let the guy pay
and then finally she took his address he
paid with cash and then she took him
cash the next day and dropped it off but
i think because of that it's made me in
some ways like i have a hard time taking
help so sometimes even when i should ask
for help like i'll have people offer and
i'm like i can't it's the way i was
brought up but my mom is like my hugest
hero but there's other people like this
is a cheesy one too but you know who i
love eminem
the rapper because
i just i love that he like
was someone who
shouldn't have made it he's a white kid
and he's rapping and then everybody
talks [ __ ] and everybody was like you
can't do what you're doing and instead
of trying to pander and fit in he was
like [ __ ] everyone and did it his own
way and still became like the hugest
star so i think that that's the problems
i have a hard time in life and in
business with listening to too many
outside voices people's opinions
and when i trust my own gut is when i go
the farthest like that in a bikini [ __ ]
you used to call me about when i used to
do those in a bikini photos which i kind
of stopped doing but
i took so much [ __ ] for doing those
photos like people
comics hated that i was doing those
photos and i remember you calling me you
and sam triple are like the two guys you
calling me and saying like oh me and my
wife think those are so funny
yeah and sam tripoli was like that [ __ ]
is hilarious and people that hate on it
are like jealous just ignore it and keep
doing it hilarious but i almost like i
literally almost changed my whole image
because of what i would hear other
people say and it was so hard for me to
like
ignore the outside noise but i think
that that's i love anyone that ignores
outside like i love joan rivers like i
love anyone that like just ignores all
the [ __ ] people say and are like this is
who i am if you don't like it [ __ ] off
basically and i'm trying to get more
like that relationally that was gonna be
my next question who is your female
hero i love joan rivers because i see
what you're doing and it's very
interesting
you know like you said earlier
we were discussing the uh the situation
in your career the humps and the bumps
you know yeah but that's one thing about
you that you always and there's times i
look at pictures that you post and i'm
like what the [ __ ] is she doing i know
you call me and on the back of my mind
i'm like she's keeping her [ __ ]
career alive she's trying to do anything
to stay that's what social media is for
see that's what we have the advantage of
you get on the show tomorrow you're on
an abc show modern family
when the show ends
you're still going to retain the people
who watch that show
because you're going to communicate with
them it's not like now that
people don't talk to kramer or whatever
the [ __ ] you know now it's different we
live in such a different social climate
so true that you can retain these people
and do comedy and they'll still come to
your shows
sometimes i do mess up i mean the thing
with social media that that i do is i
used to be really smart about brand
imaging like i have a marketing
background so i think that's why i had
good luck on social media because i see
i see how you have to brand yourself
even when you're an artist you have to
still create like a brand image for
yourself like you do you know but
the thing is sometimes i'll have moments
where i'm just in the mood or i'm not
gonna lie like sometimes as a girl
there's moments you're like i just want
some attention or or
i think something will be really funny
and i want to push a boundary like when
i did that video me peeing on the tennis
court where i showed my whole ass
i thought that was so [ __ ] funny and
i knew people were gonna talk [ __ ] but
then i was like this is one gonna get a
million views two people are gonna talk
[ __ ] which is fine three it's funny to
me
so i [ __ ] did it
and you know a lot of people did text me
and say like redband even texts me and
goes are you doing porn now what the
[ __ ] like he didn't like it but chris
sure like reposted it and liked it and
like the thing is it's just
who knows this town's a crap shoot you
throw a bunch of [ __ ] against the wall
and you see what sticks and there's
times that i think maybe i i go too far
i literally did lose an audition
recently for a show i wanted to audition
for because they were like your image
isn't right for this network so i mean i
have [ __ ] up in some ways but then i
go
i'm being myself like you can only no
don't keep doing what you're doing no
people are not gonna agree what you're
doing and you know what
you can't hate on them for that that's
just not what they're looking for i'm
over all that [ __ ] now i've been over it
for years there's nothing you could do
that's why i told you
that if you're not getting the auditions
you want and stuff
you really have to get the breakdowns
for six months
that will
make you go to the doctor
and get settings
when you're an actor yeah when you're an
actor and you get the breakdown i almost
don't want to see that let me explain
something to you this is the system you
get up out of bed
you pee
you either jump in the shower or you
brush your teeth
you drink a cup of coffee you smoke some
pot and the first thing you do
is go on the computer and print up the
breakdowns yeah and it's about 100 pages
and they have commercials yeah you don't
want to go through that i used to go
through them all you want to go through
the films
and you go through film and tv and you
make notes
and you call your agent and you leave
messages for your manager
and they start telling you stories about
how that nobody's answering the phone on
this it personally says on the breakdown
this starts shooting next friday right
but then i'll answer them the [ __ ]
phone you know yeah and then finally
your agent will call you one thing on
that project you want to go in
they had [ __ ] uh you know pamela
anderson for it but they didn't say that
on there right
you know so you learn a lot about
casting true from that perspective you
find out that that role that you should
again there was a timely
in two times when i did joey karate
i got a call from this producer they're
like listen bro
we're going to fx we got this show
called the fat man show
the fat man the fat man show
we're trying to pay you another fat dude
and then you're going to go to
restaurants you're going to do this
you're going to do that you're going to
do this you're going to do that it's
gonna be tremendous we're gonna shoot a
pilot in march it was like december
this guy jerked me off
to a week before the pilot shoot
i was furious i almost jumped off a
[ __ ] building i wanted that fat show
yeah they ended up using a kid from the
i o
and some other [ __ ] comic
that wasn't even on the road they shot a
pilot and that fx didn't pick it up so i
didn't lose no [ __ ] didn't matter it
didn't matter by the way don't you like
love the the gruffness of hollywood how
they call you and go like nowhere else
would someone call you and go hey we
have this show called the fat man show
we think you'd be a great fat guy i
chased them i chased them when i saw it
they were doing it you're like this is
perfect face them yeah i wanted
something that shot a gower right i want
to shoot something with god it's easy
but it's so funny the way they talk like
when i got my playboy tv show they said
to me i will never forget my first
production meeting i swear to god they
said kate you know why we love you so
much for the show like
you're cute but you're not threatening
like you're not the kind of girl that
other women are like oh [ __ ] my husband
will leave me for her like you're just
you know you're average but you're like
a little above average like literally
they were and i was like you know i'm
here and i could hear this right but i
mean that's in hollywood like they
almost forget that you're a person and
they're like you're basically just
you're a shell and they'll be like you
know what's great about you're not
you're like you're real looking like
your roots are shitty like your skin
isn't perfect like you could use a
little work like that's how they
literally talk to you
i think it's hilarious but i also like
it because
you know it keeps me insecure which i
need
i've worked on a couple tv shows and
i've been in the room when they're
shooting the live portion of it for
various tv shows and the director will
move the audience around he'll be like
look that woman has messed up
fingernails move her out of the shot
bring someone else in and they'll move
people around they'll have them like
move in just based on whoever looks the
best that's what's crazy when i did that
paid audience work it literally they
would come through the line and they
would choose the most attractive people
to sit in the front and they would get
paid the most so you would be like
you're getting paid between 65 and 85
depending on where you sit and then they
would kind of so you know you're like oh
i'm getting paid based on
how i look so you'd have to show up i
mean i had a gig when i first came out
here i used to be a promo girl i was
like a dodgers girl um i shot a poster
for the anaheim ducks i used to do all
these sporting events and i'll never
forget i came to work one day
wearing like not that much makeup like
less than i have on now and my boss goes
what's going on with your face
i was like what do you what do you mean
and she was like you didn't feel like
putting makeup on and i was like i
didn't think it was a big deal it's a
dodger game she was like go home
i got sent home for not wearing enough
makeup like la is brutal chicago that
should never happen you just show up and
you're like not fat and they're like
good work you're cute
like that's it
so you've busted your hump here for the
last 11 years oh dude i i mean like i've
never had a job where i had to clock in
and out i've always been freelance so
like i grew up since i was 19. so
that's the thing is i'm at least i was
always used to hustling for money when i
was in high school i dropped out of high
school i think i told you that when i
was 17 and i got an apartment and i got
a job waiting tables which is its own
hustle because you make as much as you
know you flirt like your tips are based
on how nice you are to people and then
college i started doing promo gigs so i
always gigged and then i emceed events
so like
i knew how to hustle which is i think
why when i started doing
stand up and you took to it
entertainment is the same it's how you
treat people it's how professional you
are and even though like
comics artists we get a little freelance
because we're a little nuts but at the
end of the day if you show up on time
and you're professional
you're gonna stand out there's a lot of
people that like get so [ __ ] up you
know i've seen guys go on stage hammered
and not make it through a set i mean
so there is some element of like
it's the same as any freelance job in a
way
and then you just have to also
be creative
i give you kudos i give you kudos
because
i know how tough it is to be a comic i
know how tough it is to be a female
economy
and there's a certain attitude you have
to
have to swim your way
through the sharks if you're going to be
a woman not let it get to you
not take the [ __ ]
and you do well you're out there every
night i see that you're at the store
you're at jay davies room
while everybody else is crying see that
was my thing
i always thought while everybody else
was crying i was doing something
and even if i did a rumor that paid me
20 hours i was still on stage yeah it
was going to make me that much better i
always didn't look at money
for years i never looked at money well
you can't let them i was getting on
stage i didn't give a [ __ ] what you gave
me when they gave me those three drink
tickets and a free dinner oh my god
you're so happy god you're so [ __ ]
happy i was joking at the ice house last
night i was like i'm gonna sell these
drink tickets to homeless guys outside
guys you have no idea when you first
start comedy and you're flat broke and
somebody gives you three drink tickets
and you have like seven dollars in your
pocket people don't get it and you could
tip the bartender now and sometimes you
get six free drinks instead of three
and you tip the bar ten to seven bucks
and it's [ __ ] tremendous i mean it's
all it always works out i had six drinks
i would die by the way but yeah [ __ ]
that if i was doing powder i could do
six drinks in [ __ ] 10 minutes but
that's the thing though is i think in
some ways the problem for me is i love
stand up and i i l i just love stand up
like i could be happy just doing stand
up i like acting a lot i enjoy it that's
what i went to school would you go out
every week
what and do stand up on the yeah well
that's the thing i would do weekends
like if like i would love to just do
thursday friday saturdays i i'm not a
big fan of what i've been doing which is
like the wednesday to sunday that's just
so much many nights and it's like it's a
little brutal it's lonely i've been
lucky because i've been taking red band
and like taking friends jack jr but
i mean the the problem is
i love stand up which is why i let the
acting side the tv side suffer a little
because i don't work as hard as i should
honestly at getting on tv because i just
love stand up and i don't care about
being famous like it's great when
someone comes up to me like it just
happened to me which by the way thank
you for this i was on a date
in santa monica
and a waiter who's waiting on me and my
date came up to the table i said kate
oh my god i love you on the church i
watch joey diaz i love you he goes dude
that's that story about you [ __ ]
your pants was so funny
literally on a date with this guy who
knows nothing about comedy which is why
i've wanted to go out with him and i go
um
i i'm not sure what story that is but
thank you thank you and he goes you know
the one where you said you took the
anxiety medicine you [ __ ] your pants
right before you went on stage like he
literally started explaining it to me
and i was like
that's so sweet thank you so much and
then he walked away and then i had to
tell the story to the guy i was out with
by the way we never went out again but
that's because i don't know but i love
when someone recognizes me for like my
work but like i have no desire
whatsoever to be like out at the mall
and have people know who i am so
i don't really pursue
the acting stuff as much as i need to
because you do need to you know because
you got to have both you got to have the
tv credits but
i just like doing stand-up
i'm just happy that you're around i'm
happy that you're hospital as much as
listen if you didn't hustle and if you
were just going around [ __ ] begging
for chops you wouldn't be on this show
thank you
i applaud that uh
that you're out there because i know how
tough it is and like i said
i didn't know dick about dick
i only knew where stand up was that
night that's all i knew
people come to me with these stories oh
my god you have to be at this place
this is where sean penn hangs out and
producers i go no i don't need to be
there i need to be on the stage yeah you
go to that place and you get that mind
[ __ ] there's nothing gonna happen for
you your career
if you do a spot at the mexican place
then you stop at this place on santa
monica and you end up at the store
that's three spots i was doing when i
first moved to la
yeah i was doing 400 spots a year
[ __ ] that's crazy that's three spots at
night
sunday nights that's more
that's a lot i would do let me see
yeah i would do
one to two spots seven nights a week
some nights i'd do three that was what i
yeah
that's how i was for a while saturday
nights when i lived in seattle
i got to seattle in 95.
monday and tuesday winter underground
wednesday there was three different
people who had a night either you got
paid or you got a guest spot
and thursday friday and saturday was the
same
and then sunday there was an open mic at
the underground where you got paid
so me you lee
redman we all get together do a show
yeah they give us 70 of the doing we
take the money and we go to mccormick
and schmitz
yes so that was that was it that was
you know that was uh the beginning of
your marketing like that was how you
learn all this [ __ ]
but at the same time
you're doing
we're doing what we're supposed to be
doing
i've seen i moved here kate
i went home so many nights heartbroken
because for years there was always a new
kid in town and it was never me
it was never made there was always a kid
who came in and did three spots at night
i got it and the guy from the improv
loved them
there was the guy who got the half
million dollar deal there was ten of
those guess what
when the deals went away these guys
their fortitude broke
and they're gone yeah their fortitude
broke and they're gone it's the people
who stay here and stick it out over the
years of course and you keep going out
and you keep believing in yourself and
you know what something may not happen
for seven or eight months
and then one day you get the call of a
lifetime
and you're in town all these people well
i'm gonna go home for three weeks for
the holiday go ahead [ __ ] that [ __ ] you
you're like have a great trip i'll buy
your point tickets good trip i'll send
you a call [ __ ]
some of the best auditions i've gotten
in this town have been after december no
you're so right when somebody wants to
shoot something on january 8th right the
[ __ ] monday after new year's
you want to go to work sit here
from the [ __ ] 18th to the 31st but
here's the crux i shot something one
year on christmas eve morning for the
nfl network do you understand me
i booked it like the day before for the
nfl network i love the attitude listen
to me one [ __ ] christmas i was broke
as [ __ ] yeah i didn't know what i was
gonna get my girlfriend and they used to
have a little spot
on
la cienega
across the chinese restaurant and vito's
pizza
in there there was a spot where you
auditioned
i wanted there to audition for a
god-awful italian mob thing
like god awful wasn't even italian rock
thing it was like two guys from new york
that played plumbers on an island
hot i will never forget this
dog
broke as [ __ ] yeah got a neon for a car
i shared with my wife we got one
apartment
we live in a one bedroom we would live
in a studio room hollywood baby
i go to this place dog and this dude
taps me on the shoulder and says excuse
i go to this dumb [ __ ] audition
i signed my [ __ ] stupid name
it's december 18th yeah i'll never
forget it
i signed my stupid name yeah i got seven
days to get my [ __ ] girlfriend
a christmas present
and sending my daughter something like i
was like [ __ ] waiting the only thing
i had coming in was the 115 check from
the comedy store on friday yeah
hopefully i'll get a main room spot
and i can at least get dinner for
christmas eve oh and then i'll never
forget that i walked in there i the
movie the movie if we shoot the movie's
gonna shoot in february what the [ __ ] am
i doing here december 11th
you know i'm saying december 18th i took
the movie was shooting january 1st so i
walk out i'm a little bummed out
and you know as i'm about to hit the
corner
this [ __ ] guy comes out like this
little nazi excuse me excuse me
might talk to you sir
i don't like what's going on
he's like are you union
and then i go yeah i'm muted he goes
it's a shame
it's a shame he had a non-union project
because i haven't done union project
you're perfect for you're like i'll do
it and he goes and pays cash
i go really
and it was like 3 000
i had never seen 3 000 out here
i [ __ ] went inside i read the role
i got it the next day i had to drive up
to valencia they gave me a hotel
overnight nice i gotta stop at d-mans
get a half get a little bundle of rock
sad night in the hotel i could [ __ ]
blast off and look out a window so it
was a two-day shoot three g's
buy out non-union commercial for
switzerland perfect it was a [ __ ] uh
for switzerland snickers commercial two
mobsters drive up in the [ __ ] that
was the sopranos were hot that's how it
always happens two mafia guys drive up
we drove up to valencia i lived i stayed
in the hotel room shot the next day
six o'clock at night the sun was going
on it was starting to get cold
they placed an envelope in my hand and i
[ __ ] shot home i had breaks like that
every
that happens in december when
everybody's leaving
everybody's going home i remember one
time i wanted for a show that they were
gonna fire artie lang
that when that dude had the show they
were gonna they were gonna replace him
yeah
i've sat here through years of this [ __ ]
listen one thing i've learned is that
you wake up every morning
you do the best you can do you write
your goals you take care of yourself you
take care of your health
and one day
somebody's gonna call you and say hey
man we got this audition for this
[ __ ] role it's always i don't know
it's a kirk cameron film or whoever the
[ __ ]
go in there and knock it out of the
parking next thing you know you're
working on a feature film in new york
they're gonna give you 175 a day per
diem and you're there for three weeks
jack
you know and that's it that's it you're
there
while you're there you're going to think
about doing spots and you're going to go
what am i doing
we've talked about that i'm here to
shoot a [ __ ] movie i'm not here to do
15-minute spots i remember you telling
me that when i was shooting my my show
because i was trying to do spots on the
road when i was shooting and you're like
just do your show concentration focus on
your show
that's who's going to see you those are
the people that bring you back you go on
your show [ __ ] half who bots you're
right they're going to go she's half
[ __ ] up you know what i'm saying it's
true no i'm happy you know i like the
whole uh hustling thing i'm from the old
[ __ ] hustle school
you know uh
when i was a kid man
when my mom first died i moved them with
this family called the benders and the
benders were great john was great the
whole the whole family was great i was
just the [ __ ] up
but while i lived with them i met two
brothers
and uh one of them i was tighter with
than the other one and me and him were
kind of crazy and [ __ ] and we snort blow
and i told him i was getting thrown out
of the [ __ ] runnies you know i was
getting thrown out of the benders
and that's all i said to him it's like
if i tell you you don't want lisa to
throw me out pretty soon yeah and one
day he came to me at school and he goes
i talked to my father you can move him
with us
if he throws johnny and you're throwing
me out by that point he's just moving to
it
like who does that type of [ __ ] you know
what i'm saying
that's really dope so i moved in one of
my little for about a year and a half
and i robbed the jewelry store
i went to sarasota and hid for a couple
of [ __ ] months and
i came back and i didn't move in with
him but we remained friends and
i mean tight tight like he came to my
wedding
you know he was there when they
sentenced me to prison
he wrote a letter or you know he's just
uh
we just stayed in touch he was a [ __ ]
crazy man
and then in 92
i got into a little trouble in boulder
you know i went through a divorce and i
was having a hard time
i was starting to get the comment i just
called them up one day they listen man
it ain't working out for me
this is just not working out here i'm
gonna [ __ ] you know no way you were
gonna leave you sent me a plane ticket
and i
went to some guy who sells xanax with
the visa and i refer to the thousand of
them
and i took him back to jersey and that's
how i started my life with a thousand
xanax i sold shut up and i had like 800
bucks but he let me stay with him and
his pregnant wife and that kid on the
floor on the couch and he would lend me
his honda
to go to auditions and to go to [ __ ]
different open mics i didn't even know
what i was doing yeah and then they had
to move so i ended up going to cliffside
but he still stayed my brother
and we're still we still talk every 10
days he's got four kids two of his kids
come to my comedy shows
the whole [ __ ] thing
yeah this has been a 40-year maybe
45-year friendship
just amazing and
a week ago his daughter his 18 year old
daughter woke up on a monday and said
she was having a hard time breathing
because she had pneumonia they took her
to the hospital or she's at the hospital
they realized that she had some form of
leukemia that her
niece you were talking about
she had the white blood cells dropped
and it was
something in the red blood cells
and they kept her over there at night
and did a test and it was came back yeah
she had cancer
but it's not in her organs and it's not
her brain it's treatable so it's
treatable so she lucked out they put her
in this hospital in philly and it's
on the top three hospitals in the
[ __ ] country for that type of
treatment for kids
and
they tried to backtrack the insurance
because she doesn't make any money
she just started her job she just
graduated high school so crazy isn't it
so they backtracked their insurance that
it's going to cover
but they pretty much told the parents
that it's going to run up a half a
million [ __ ] dollars no way even with
all the programs
it's four weeks in the hospital five
weeks six weeks
and then you have to go back there
every week once a week for treatment for
like a year or two or something so they
get it right so
it's expensive
so you know me guys i don't
i put up a link before you give 50 cents
it helps if you can't you know me they
know beef
everybody's trying to fight everybody's
trying to put two nickels together
yeah it just helps out who knows yeah if
everyone gave 50 cents i'll cover it
what's that i said if everyone gave 50
cents they would just about recover
listen you know i don't get mad at
nobody i don't give a [ __ ] about that it
makes me so sad you can't donate to
everything
no you can't but it's just it's it's
crazy that it's 2017
and we don't have like a health care
system that takes care of you it's
absolutely listen they do this this is
the all these hospitals saint jude half
a million dollars
listen it's 1.5 million in the treatment
oh
you're paying for you know you're just
assuming i mean how is it one point five
hundred million dollars we're talking
about the house before i go honey what
happens if i walk in the house and
there's three feet of [ __ ] water she
goes well here's the problem we would
get a check but the first five thousand
it's a five thousand dollars
right so we would swallow that they
would they would pay for the furniture
but you know blah blah blah blah blah
blah yeah yeah
but it's like insane that it's 1.5
million dollars to treat one person's
cancer like how is it how does it even
cost that much how is it possible that
the medication treatment to treat one
group
costs a million dollars that's insane
listen
it's impossible you sit there and you go
home but then you think about if it's
your child
if it's your child it's going to save
her life oh of course you do it would
you do anything and that's why you can't
defend it but yeah of course i would
sell i would do it my mom's one of those
hospitals that after you become a part
of it
then when somebody else's child gets it
you pass money on to them yeah it's a
retribution type thing so it's not like
you're going to jail no or they're going
to cancel your [ __ ] visa card or
anything yeah but you still have a half
a million dollars worth of debt on yours
it's so it's just it's insane to me but
they have a bunch of grants
so they're trying to do all they could
alexa the sister
set up a link and i put it on twitter
early uh sunday night later sunday night
so
if you want to give a dollar no i feel
bad for my brother
and i want to do something nice for him
i'm gonna go
visit him and her
on my way to pittsburgh and spend the
night over there and see them
yeah i hang out with them go get some
chinese food in philadelphia or
something like that
or something or a cheesesteak or
something
smoke some reefer i'll see my niece oh
i'll see you at the house with a mother
at the hospital you know
when uh i first moved back from
i was in [ __ ] up shape i just got into
a divorce
you know i lost my [ __ ] credit which
i [ __ ]
i was crazy about my credit i made all
my payments me too [ __ ] me too i'm
obsessed
you know i'm like i'm poor but i have
perfect credit
i [ __ ] i didn't have rent to pay my
roommate rent money
i was doing blow i i
asian chick broke my [ __ ] heart i
just
kicked it to the curb and stepped on it
her [ __ ] was so good
[Laughter]
so i just left like a [ __ ] beat up
bag back to new jersey and he paid for
everything and his wife was pregnant
yeah he's family
so he met me cut me a deal he go look do
me a favor
stay at home with my wife watch tv i'm
gonna go out and play darts and do my
thing
i'll give you a package you give me like
a half a gram so i had something to do
at night when i was oh boy
he loved you oh i loved him that's why i
got to do this so i would sit there with
his wife
i would roll a joint go downstairs smoke
and i come upstairs and she go you
hungry i'm hungry
and we call a chinese restaurant to see
caucus new jersey it was tremendous they
were open until midnight
we go there about 11 30 and we get egg
rolls pork fried rice
we bring them back to our house and me
and her throw in good fellas
and we and we do that four nights a week
yeah
she was gaining weight because of the
baby i was gaining weight because i was
eating chinese food every night at 11 30
at night
on saturday she would give me money to
go get it at this deli they had
with these stuffed [ __ ] peppers
and they were stuffed with prosciutto i
mean this deli was [ __ ] delicious
sounds so good making me hungry for the
last two or three months of her
pregnancy i was there with her
i stayed in with her and then the other
nights i was out doing comedy like i was
out in the city standing on the line in
front of a [ __ ] coffee shop and [ __ ]
it was a [ __ ] horror show
it was really look at you now
but i almost quit those days and i would
go over there those days were right glad
you didn't i had to go get a backstage
and you used to have to go on the
backstage and see where the open mics
were
and i remember like going into hamburger
harry's and
yell triple in i went to some [ __ ]
creepy places there was one place i will
never forget i went to this place i'm
like
it was across the street from goodfellas
pizza
on the upper on the lower west side
on like 8th avenue and 20 and 18th
street yeah and it was there was
something on the corner and this bar was
the second bar and they had an open mic
i still had thoughts of that in my mind
like the things i learned in there
there was never ever more than five
people in there really listening you
mean audiences yeah wow never more than
five people yeah the guy who ran the
room was cool and there'd be so many
comics there
that you thought there were 60 people in
there yeah it was all kind of so i made
it like a hangout i forget the name of
the place that's cool though oh my god
but i would go there and i learned so
much and like i just went down that bomb
you walk out of there going what the
[ __ ] am i doing i was talking about that
last night i was like you know sometimes
i think it would just be fun to go up
and just bomb on purpose just for fun
just every once in a while like
literally last night i was like you have
to yeah just just for fun if you don't
bomb
25 percent of the time you're not really
a comic because you're not taking
chances you got to try new stuff i go up
there i don't give a [ __ ] anything yeah
yeah the main room i used to always trip
on it for years and recently because
there's so many producers that are
producing rooms in there yeah i've
gotten really good in the main room now
because i flip it on
it took me 10 years to learn how to work
that room really
bro i bombed in there the first time why
do you think
i think i'm an o-r type of guy yeah
i think the or's harder now over the
years i've learned how to adjust to the
main room especially now that those
promoters do a great job those people
are packed all the time they're [ __ ]
packed in there yeah but for years i go
in that main room and just eat a bag of
[ __ ] decks no way i would even tell
her don't [ __ ] put me back there no
more and she would put me back there to
follow don herrera
who 15 years ago was a hammer back there
you think he's a hammer now he's so
[ __ ] funny he would take you on a
psychological ride
and i would go up there trying to be
dirty and it would just be a death kiss
it would just be horrible you know a
story someone told me about you recently
i have a friend he's been doing comedy
for like 14 years or something super
funny guy he said this is like years ago
he said this had to be like eight years
ago or something he was headlining a
show at the old haha
and uh he said he went up and he said it
was like the best study ever had he goes
i felt like i killed so hard audience
loved me i was like i'm gonna hang after
everybody's gonna [ __ ] tell me how
awesome i was he said it was the best
that he ever had and then he said while
he was on stage you showed up and you
weren't supposed to go on but you he
said you popped by and you wanted to go
up so like yeah you can go up after this
guy so he said he was like i killed the
room and i came off and then joey went
up and he goes within three minutes
of watching joey he goes the crowd is
[ __ ]
losing their [ __ ] he goes what i thought
was killing the room was nothing
compared to the first three minutes that
joey was on stage he goes he murdered so
hard i left he goes i left i didn't want
to see the audience after he was like
i'm not gonna ever say i killed again
until i'm that funny that was a story he
told me about you the other day
and i was like that's that's amazing he
goes yeah i watched him and was like oh
that's the level that's the level i want
to be out when i say i killed
it
really yup that happened to me with stan
home really
1996 in seattle i'm a feature act and
[ __ ]
i'm a bad [ __ ] i had her i had
met stan hope before
he had just won the san francisco comedy
competition
he was hot but there's a thousand comics
that come through the great that after
you watch me like
yeah this is garbage
i'm up down with my girlfriend
i'm excited
she just finished stripping her hands
are sticky
hot
we're sitting there and this kid goes up
there and just starts throwing a beating
on the room
like i never saw oh stan hope
oh he had come on he came in with a
reputation of a killer he was the
hottest yeah
in hollywood he was a regular at the
store he was disrupting the emperor
so i said i knew him i knew him
from the broker
he stayed at my house both times when he
had come through that
yeah so i went to see you know i i kept
hearing the bottom and
somebody goes you're talking about doug
stanhope he's on fire right now
and i'm a comic and i think that you
know i didn't think i was great
right things were happening i was in a
great direction i was in a great comedy
it felt good i had just done the
festival i came in sixth
behind the the black girl that's popular
now who's the black girl she was on the
view or something wanda sykes no um the
one that was a comic from the laugh
factory and she told jamie to [ __ ] off
anyway it doesn't [ __ ] matter oh i
think i know you're talking she's at the
comedy show the other night i can't
remember her name i know looking black
chick but she's half white and she
doesn't play off black
that's not you should try oh are you
sure okay
aisha took fifth that year
and i forget who took first
but
i like seattle i was doing well
i go on a date we jump into the late
show
and what i saw doug stanhope doing up
there was total annihilation yeah
like i stayed and want like at the 25
minute mark
i thought to myself you know what
i'm quitting copy
because i'm never going to be doing it
yeah this is what you need to be yeah if
you're not doing what he's doing right
now
you're [ __ ] missing the boat that was
june of 96 i saw that
and i went home and i canceled the next
night i had like a gig at like an eight
naval base or something no
i called her at like one and i said i'm
sick
and i was like that was too much for me
to even watch dude it's crazy that was
too much for once you get that inspired
now you know
yep like i feel bad for your friend
but
you shouldn't that was the only thing i
had over him at the time
was time and experience
experience means that
for [ __ ] 15 years
i threw myself into the weirdest
situations
like i i was a fiend yeah so i would
take any gate you got a bar room
i remember darren carter me going to a
bar and darren carter calling me and
telling me like the week before he got a
knife thrown out of there shut up
an audience member who didn't like him
rick martinez do you know rick martinez
no there's a dude rick martinez he's
still around he still lingers from time
to time okay
he used to book all these crazy shows
and he had one show in a room in
oceanside california and it was all big
fat samoans
and if you went and did fat jokes they
throw knives at you
and darren told the guy to get up and do
push-ups or something and the guy threw
a
knife that's amazing
a knife listen guys you're sitting at
home going what is the life of a couple
people understand there are moments
there there are moments you feel like
you're on top of the world and there are
moments you're like i should give like
when i did the avian awards i remember i
had a really great set at the avian
awards and everyone warned me it was
gonna be terrible so i remember coming
off and being like that was amazing i i
did so well there's so many people here
i rehearsed like i felt so good i felt
like on top of the world right then i
came back to la and then i was hosting a
show at the comedy store like two nights
later or something and uh louis ck
dropped in and he went up and then rogan
was going after him and i'm hosting and
louis ck is about to come off he's got
the light and rogan's running late in
the or and they're like kate just do
like four or five minutes just kill time
i'm like you want me to do five minutes
between louis c.k and joe rogan and then
i had this moment of like what the [ __ ]
am i gonna do and then i went out and i
tried to do you know i made a joke like
about having to like every comic's worst
nightmare having to like do time after
louis ck and then i tried to do like a
bit like a three-minute bit but it was
like so [ __ ] terrible
i mean so bad the laughs i was getting
compared to the laughs he was getting
and in my head i remember just being
like uh this is the last time i'm ever
going to go on stage here like that's
literally what i was thinking well as
you update you're thinking that like i
bombed really bad at the improv
in between stan hope and nick apollo
yeah i saw
it wasn't that i bombed so bad i bombed
twice at the improv
i bombed at the black shell one night
where you could hear crickets
really
have you ever been in a club where you
actually could hear crickets because
that happened to me once i actually
could hear crickets backstage
i bombed at the improv about 18 months
later
on a thursday night packed house
and there was some [ __ ] hitters on
there yeah and i got sandwiched in the
middle
and i went up there and i think i bailed
at the end but it was a horrendous set
and i swear to god this is exactly what
i did you ready yeah
i
went to the comedy store i did my spot
i did mediocre on purpose because i had
already made my decision
what was that really made my decision
what was your decision i went i bought
the 220s from the guy
i went home
i got a notebook i did coke all night
and that morning at six in the morning i
[ __ ]
sent the facts to the guy with the with
the missing ear that books the pacific
northwest
and i told him to give me all the work
he had though
and he gave and he i told him just give
me headline work dude i guess and i
[ __ ] did
i mean i disappeared yeah i left
in november like i was so ashamed
i did the remaining spots i had that
week and i just went underground
i was so embarrassed i got in a [ __ ]
car
first i started the tour in new york i
went to new york around my family
i did all the rascals those are five
hundred dollars and no money weeks we
left i did all that [ __ ] rascals boston
i did all that during the holidays and
then i came back here got different
clothes
did a week in texas with somebody and
then me and a girl got in the car and
drove all the way from houston
to oregon and we did five weeks up in
the pacific northwest without coming
home damn
and then from there we came through l.a
changed clothes
and went right back to el paso we went
to all those [ __ ] places all over
again when i came back from those nine
months
a different comment that was a different
comic yeah it was a different comment
even five weeks but then
i had to retrain myself in the la
different county
because now you're rough from the road
you just got out of prison you're
tougher than nails you've done push-ups
every day you learned how to write
you've been focused you've been
disciplined
but now
that joke about tuscaloosa is not going
to work in l.a people are going to call
you a hack and you're also doing like an
hour on the road and you're doing 12
minutes here now you're doing 12 so now
you got to get your act
to be sharpened for los angeles and
that's a completely different [ __ ]
story and that's what other people
understand it is crazy though too here
because people don't realize you can be
so young in comedy and have to follow
ron what like i mean you just never know
who's gonna pop in even on a bringer
show even on a show at the comedy store
that like you shouldn't even be on yet i
had to follow ron white at the improv
one night and it was i mean he's so hard
to fall he's so [ __ ] funny but no you
can't look at okay
there's two ways to follow [ __ ] funny
people
there's the way that you walk up there
defeated
no well there's the way that you walk up
there like he's just another comic for
years i followed the heat at the store
and for years i ate a bag of dicks and
i'll tell you why
because on the way up i lost mentally it
was in your head that's the stage
i said it out loud
i would say it like give another run a
block yeah he's a legend
he's a [ __ ] savage and then i would
defeat myself yeah saying
how am i gonna follow that and right
there it's over yeah yeah you just
killed yourself you just shot yourself
in the foot that's true now
like you have to
you have to
follow energy with energy
that's why right now they're not scared
of irma no more they're scared of jose
yep because energy follows energy
so if you go up in front like i'll tell
you who's really good at following
people
allie wong
oh yeah she's going to follow dalia or
ron white not cause she's great
because she changes
the tempo of the room
i was gonna say though don't you think
it's something about because i feel like
for me it's like and i mean everyone
says this but it's like when you find
your voice
but because really now like i'm gonna be
me no matter like i used to the first
club that ever paid me in l.a was the
j-spot have you ever been there down by
the airport yes it is so black it is the
[ __ ] is it still open uh i haven't
been there in like probably two years so
i i think it is though i saw billboards
when you come back to the year i think
it is i think it is
but like
they were paying me before i ever should
have gotten paid this was like seven
eight years ago they would pay me to
come on the weekends i think that they
just wanted a cute white girl i would be
the only white person
there comic or crowd right and that room
is so black i mean the guys are wearing
pimp suits and canes and i mean it's so
urban
i would go up and [ __ ] bomb so bad
because i would try to play to them
instead of just being myself instead of
just doing the same [ __ ] i would do
anywhere else i would try to like
match the energy of all the other comics
and when i finally stopped doing that i
started having good sets there but i
think that's what it is i think it's
like there's some moment where you
finally go
this is my [ __ ] this is my voice this is
i'm going to be me no i started a black
club i started a club club mix
and on sunday nights club mex mix
where's that it used to the dj kwame
booked it on sunday night
dj and that's how i met uh
uh the entertainer
that was here in l.a denver oh he's
colfax boulevard
club mix and the guy whose name is kwame
and kwame's claim to fame was that he
was out here in l.a for a while doing
spots at the [ __ ] store amazing
so if you ever go by the store tell them
kwan may sent you
so when i came out here i'm like kwame
sent me and they're like go [ __ ]
yourself
was very good for me on sunday nights he
would take me out to this place
and i bet i was doing comedy for two
years i was confused i didn't know who
the [ __ ] i was on stage and i would go
out there and i would come out with
music i did something that none of the
other white dudes did i went there and i
watched the white dudes come out
straight and they would eat a bag of
dicks
i would come out to a black funky music
and come on dance i knew it and then i'd
take the microphone
and run with it from there and whatever
happened would happen i would you
dancing is funny i would call them i
would call three black chicks tlc
i will call this one to james brown's
uncle
and you get through the 10-minute set
that i suck
absolutely but it didn't matter i was
learning black audiences yeah once you
start bot like i bombed in front of
black audiences and i quit
excuse me
and then i figured out how to go back
and do well
now guess what i'm going to be as honest
i can with you i do not want to do a 3
000 seat
tour with a black comic i would bomb
but if you have a 200 seat one night or
something that you want me to do
and you know it's a couple black dudes
that either i know i don't know i don't
give a [ __ ] i do it yeah it's the big
ones where i'll bomb they go into my
mental state
and i bomb but
it taught me a lot doing comedy selling
your soul for comedy like what you were
doing and what i was doing when i got
here latino comedy was going to be the
next big thing
everybody white all of a sudden became
latino
kate quigley was half cuban her uncle
and her mother like that still happens
it was still everybody was [ __ ]
spanish yeah so it was a big explosion
you know what i'm saying so you would
write comedy
for that genre yeah and that genre by
doing that in la you would do good on
those nights but then you would take
that out to the comedy store and you
suck a bag of dicks with it because it
wasn't trans
it wasn't crying over damn
i feel actually now like i recently did
uh a really like an all black kind of
theater show and
i feel like now i do well at it but
because i can relate to black women
because i'm i'm insane and i like go
crazy on guys and so do black girls and
latin girls so i feel like i understand
that energy of like i will beat your
[ __ ] ass which i feel like a lot of
black women like black women don't put
up with [ __ ]
i feel like i my inner black woman comes
out
i love black women though that's good
for you
[Laughter]
when i go lesbian my wife which i'm very
close to will be a black woman
well i'm happy i might be thank you
martin luther king marched all those
years
so that i can marry a black girl
yeah this weekend
kate and i will be at the cherokee
casino
in siloam springs oklahoma it's a
saturday night show
it [ __ ] sold out last time within
[ __ ] you know so i'm telling you
right now don't [ __ ] around it's going
to be tremendous we're getting on
saturday we're doing the show when we
get out of there tim peptu
and that's it it's going to be a great
weekend i'm happy you came on okay i'm
so excited oh you know actually uh i got
a bunch of stuff coming up you can just
go on my social media at kate q funny
but a big one i'm excited about me and
red band are going to go do indianapolis
and columbus in november and then i
think we're trying to set up new york
comedy fest that weekend that's november
8th and 9th so columbus funny bone on
the ninth and indianapolis on the eighth
what club is indeed do you know marty's
okay yeah morty morty's
club morty's it'll be fun what's up with
you lee everything all right we took you
push you to the limits tonight
look at the shape of you he's doing good
[ __ ] yeah every time i look at him he's
falling asleep
he's making noises
he finally watched narcos narcos was
great did you enjoy it my brother i
really don't want to get i'm not going
near a motorcycle anytime soon let me
ask you this did you enjoy reading the
[ __ ] subtitles no i thought about you
when i was watching i'm like this is
[ __ ] up
and you got to read subtitles and stuff
yeah i know it sucks i mean but that
shows how interesting it is for me so
i'll read it but it does like i have to
like pause for like five minutes after
each episode
okay that's good to know it's a lot of
[ __ ] reading you guys are a lot of
knowledge you know let's see
i want to learn spanish he says no don't
learn spanish who you why wouldn't i why
not
i don't know i always tell you to learn
spanish we don't know spanish you have
[ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah you know a little bit
but take one they're promoting a new app
that you can learn a language on your
phone yes and somebody and i saw like a
news thing about it and then i saw an ad
for it like 10 days later
so there's a new app so you can learn
spanish at home 10 minutes a day
10 minute classes a day very cool that's
it you stick with it within a year your
pavarotti's nephew you'll be singing
songs in spanish about soul
everybody's nothing whatever the [ __ ] i
don't know is the italian i don't know
what the [ __ ] paparazzi
bob we used to call this girl in
hollywood pavarotti
when we lived in this building there was
this hot chick that was like a milf type
uh-huh but she's still stripped from
time to time you can tell she had a
little wing to it real hot looking mom
you know i'm saying yeah she'd get a
little coked up and [ __ ] but she had a
daughter that was chubby as [ __ ]
and she had eyebrows like barbarity the
italian oh [ __ ] you know what paparazzi
yeah
well she had his eyebrows and
wow we were hot we were high as [ __ ] i'm
just sure she loves seeing you guys
what a great compliment for a woman you
have pavarotti's eyebrows
we used to call the pavarotti
and she would go why do you guys call me
pavarotti i wonder why and they're like
because there's a girl that we used to
know that was her name and you kind of
look like she's pretty hot so for years
we called it
me and my friends were how
that's horrible paparazzi i wonder what
guys guys probably call me some awful
[ __ ]
[ __ ] it who cares
whatever they can't talk that [ __ ]
around me they don't like they i love
you too that's why i like you lee
everything good over there you're gonna
have a good week yeah it's a whole new
[ __ ] week this week [ __ ] it's
monday all right
listen
i know i know i know the [ __ ] it's
raining out and there's floods and
houston's recovering but this is america
[ __ ] it's going to be a
tremendous week this [ __ ] ain't going to
do nothing the [ __ ] thing destroyed
cuba it's already a category 2 by the
time it hits [ __ ] tampa so we're
gonna be fine all right you you left
with your life
you're in an auditorium right now with a
bunch of stinky [ __ ] rednecks rubbing
their feet
but at least you're [ __ ] safe what
would you rather do be in your house
it's [ __ ] flooded
they showed pictures of downtown miami
and brickell
it's [ __ ] up down there crazy it's
[ __ ] crazy so have they checked uh
have they checked on the guys who lived
or stayed on the boats i haven't even
seen them i don't know i know that
they're already you know
and this is what bothers me about that
[ __ ]
that there's always somebody who thinks
they're [ __ ] cute
i've done a lot of bad things but they
were already looting
oh no i just see the [ __ ] black dudes
that broke like the sneaker store
and it was like
10 of them away
they were losing everything
already in fort lauderdale sucks crazy
but that's right listen every time
remember people see a hurricane as a
scam time
criminal look at then what happened i
had katrina who went to jail the mayor
for what corruption he stole the [ __ ]
money you know everybody gives money you
don't know where it goes if everybody
gives 10 [ __ ] dollars where the [ __ ]
do you know where it goes it goes to the
red cross the red cross flies you down
there first class you know so what are
you talking about you're following
saying here it's kind of like kind of
weird you're right
so what do we care we're trying to put
the pieces together ourselves i don't
know what you're doing with your life
but let me tell you something all right
every time i get in the lift car when i
go to the airport or when i'm in a
strange [ __ ] town
i always feel great i feel like uh
the car is clean the driver is always
really cool
i can see who the [ __ ] they are because
when they pull up they got a little sign
in front
it's a professional operation what i'm
trying to tell you is
lyft knows that they're drivers or keep
them moving
so they do everything they can to make
sure that drivers are happy on every
trip
it's a simple formula happy drivers mean
happy passengers
maybe that's why nine out of ten lift
rides get a perfect five-star rating you
can earn hundreds of dollars a week plus
tips you want to earn more money you
drive more it's that easy
you've never been easier to give
yourself a raise lift was the first
rideshare platform with tipping built
right in to the app because getting
tipped shouldn't depend on your
passenger having a crumpled bill in
their pocket like some mooc to law
you keep 100 of your tips and they add
up fast all right drivers have been paid
over 200 million dollars since the
feature was introduced and express pay
lets you get paid
instantly instead of waiting for weeks
for your money like something got owned
lyft has even taken the guesswork out of
your pickups the new amp device uses
color coding to help passengers
find their driving
i like lyft so join the ride sharing
company
that believes in treating its people
better go to lyft.com
joey today and i'm gonna get you a 500
new driver bonus who's better than uncle
joey nobody go to
lyft.com
joey again
go to lyft.com slash joey i'm going to
get you a 500
new driver bonus
limited time only terms applied
number two you're gonna make so much
money
you're gonna be able to buy a house and
when you go to buy a house i don't want
you to get ripped off you know why
because you're gonna go to your bank
you've been with your bank for 15 years
okay
and all of a sudden you got home for a
mortgage and guess what they do they
give you a house
that's huge they give you enough money
to buy like scarface's house
and you look at it you know you know
what wow i got a million or two to buy a
house aren't they nice [ __ ] no
[ __ ] no
you're making a mistake if you do go
with them this is why i come to you with
one company and one company only
london tree
did you know that depending on where you
get your mortgage you could save 20 000
or more no you didn't
but 80 percent of people only get one
mortgage offer like we did and if you
just go to your bank
chances are you'll get ripped off okay
and i'm telling you this for a personal
experience you want to do that
lendingtree doesn't want that to happen
here's the thing the average lending
tree customer can save twenty thousand
of their the life of their loan and
that's just the average half of their
customers could save even more
whether you're looking for a new
mortgage refinance or home equity loan
lendingtree is the only place where
you're going to get five real offers
from america's top lenders
and they can compare side by side for
free and guess what
it only takes three minutes it's like
shopping for a flight online only you're
shopping
for the best mortgage available to you
rates always go up and down but
regardless of what's happening with the
rates you can always get the right offer
for you with lendingtree.com
what i'm going to do is this because i
love you the debt
and i want you to have the best deal
find out how much you can save today at
lendingtree.com
church
again that's lendingtree.com
church listen to me i'm going to save
you some money you're going to hit me up
in a few days and go joey you're a
genius
lendingtree.com
joey london tree llc
nmls
one one three six terms and conditions
apply all right
listen i'm hooking you up it's either
lyft
or london tree who's better than your
uncle joey nobody i want to thank the
most beautiful girl in the world kate
quigley oh i love you my little [ __ ]
christ killer nephew over there
lee say yeah but most importantly i want
to thank you [ __ ] and don't
forget i'll see you this weekend
cherokee casino over there in siloam
springs are you kidding me
or what
and then in two weeks i'll be at the
pittsburgh improv
stay black uncle joey loves you see you
in two days
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
my
[Music]
is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
oh
[Music]
jorge
[Music]
so
[Music]
me
[Music]
uh
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
you